monsieur le ministre collègue rien n'est
jamais définitivement acquis il suffira
d'une crise politique économique ou
religieuse pour que les droits des
femmes soient remis en question votre
vie durant vous devrez rester vigilante
ces mots de Simone de Beauvoir furent
prononcés en 1974
à la lumière du présent il nous livre un
constat terrible l'histoire des droits
des femmes à quelque chose
d'implacablement répétitif car s'il est
en invariant de notre civilisation
humaine c'est la domination des hommes
sur les femmes et les véhicules de
contrôle sur leur corps les États-Unis
la Pologne la Hongrie l'Italie est
d'autres pays en Europe ce sont déjà
engouffrés dans cette guerre impitoyable
réduisant les femmes à un sort misérable
nous savons qu'à chaque sursaut
réactionnaire les droits des femmes sont
en première ligne j'ai une pensée émue
pour Isabelle et agnieschka deux femmes
polonaises mortes de ne pas avoir pu
avorter dans de bonnes conditions
car collègue la restriction des droits
sexuels et reproductifs n'a jamais
abouti jamais à une diminution du nombre
d'avortement les femmes ont toujours
avorté même au péril de leur vie avant
1975 si les mieux lotis partaient à
l'étranger les autres ingurgités de
l'eau oxygénée du détergent du vinaigre
s'introduisez dans l'utérus une aiguille
à tricoter un épi de blé une brosse à
dents de l'eau savonneuse pour mettre un
terme à leur grossesse voici la réalité
des sévices que des femmes pouvaient
s'infliger entraînant parfois leur mort
car oui la seule conséquence de la
privation des femmes du droit à avorter
c'est l'avortement clandestin et le plus
souvent la mort le destin de ces lois et
pour les femmes et toujours finesse
collègue personne ne peut prédire
l'avenir introduire le droit à la
contraception et à l'avortement dans
notre Constitution c'est conjurer ici
cette effroi qui nous saisit lorsqu'ils
les droits des femmes font l'objet de
coups de boutoir il s'agit de donner un
socle à notre vigilance afin de parer au
basculement imprévisible dont seul
l'histoire humaine a le secret
certes nous le faisons en conscience
qu'il est demeure assez tenaces pour y
graver un droit pour l'éternité mais les
droits fondamentaux à nos yeux doivent
bénéficier de la plus grande garantie
que nous pouvons leur conférer cette
proposition de loi vise à se prémunir
d'une régression en faisant de l'attente
à ses droits l'attache la plus ardu
possible
quiconque souhaitant s'y attaquer devra
avoir les mains liées notre souhait est
clair nous ne voulons laisser aucune
chance aux personnes hostiles à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
et à la contraception
voici la question posée en creux de ce
texte souhaitez-vous laisser une chance
pour vendeur du droit à l'avortement et
la contraception si votre réponse est
non vous n'avez plus qu'à le voter car
comme nous vous trouveriez insupportable
en recul sur ses droits en revanche si
vous souhaitez leur laisser une chance
soyez clair sur le fond car à vous
entendre il n'y aurait ici que des
obstructeurs mais personne d'hostile à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
cessez d'avancer masquer quel propos les
femmes n'ont-elles pas entendu sur le
droit à disposer d'elle-même vos
amendements nous servent les pensifs les
plus écoles les femmes devraient avoir
l'autorisation de leur compagnon de leur
mari pour avorter les mineurs devraient
être privés de ce droit l'embryon et le
fœtus serait des enfants à naître
l'avortement devrait être présenté comme
un drame oui l'histoire est quelque
chose de terriblement répétitif des
années 70 à nos jours la teneur des
débats n'a pas changé
ici même les frontières s'effacent le
prétendu cordon sanitaire qui sépare les
différentes nuances de droites devient
lâche ainsi les amendements LR se
confondent avec ceux de l'extrême droite
tous deux réunis dans une même passion
en style droit des femmes un continuum
misogyne se dessine sous nos yeux
collègue
vos résistances n'ont rien d'original
tant le contrôle du corps des femmes
s'inscrit dans une histoire millénaire
sachez que la bigoterie parlementaire
est un oxymore le sort des femmes n'a
pas à dépendre de vos conservatismes
personnels vous pensez à appartenir à
vos convictions quand vos convictions
n'appartiennent qu'à la longue histoire
de la domination masculine ailleurs vos
avatars voient leur monde mourir et
tenter d'y donner un dernier sursis
c'est donc dans ce moment précis de
l'histoire que le Parlement sonnerait à
voter cette proposition de loi en
introduisant ses droits dans la
Constitution la France s'illustrerait
comme une nation pionnière en matière
des droits des femmes c'est avec cette
certitude que nous avons collectivement
réfléchi aux différentes rédactions
possibles de ce texte il s'agit d'un
travail transportant et je tiens ici à
saluer à remercier mes collègues
monsieur Balan madame violent madame
Baptiste Madame faussillon et Monsieur
Yordanov
introduire le droit à la contraception
et à l'avortement dans notre
Constitution c'est aussi formuler la
promesse suivante aux nouvelles
générations vos mères ne seront pas
mieux protégés que vous c'est faire acte
de progrès humain en affirmant
collectivement à la nécessité de ses
droits c'est une manière de briser enfin
cette partition historique entre la
sphère privée et politique voulant que
les droits sexuels et reproductifs
soient un propre à entrer dans notre
texte suprême les droits à l'avortement
et à la contraception vont de pair et ne
sont pas une affaire de bonne femme ses
droits ne doivent être cantonnés à la
sphère du domicile assignant les femmes
à des tâches silencieuses de
reproduction sociale non les droits
sexuels et reproductifs sont la
condition de possibilité de notre
communauté politique et relève de
l'égalité et de la citoyenneté
j'achève en vous disant que je ne suis
pas venue seule ici une pétition adore
et déjà recueilli 160 000 signatures
citoyennes pour l'inscription de ses
droits dans la Constitution car derrière
une proposition de loi il y a toujours
une foule une foule guidée par une
Alassane quête d'émancipation de
maîtrise de sa propre existence une
foule de femmes et d'hommes de
militantes infatigables d'associations
et de collectifs sans lesquels un droit
n'a fleur pas auprès du grand nombre
comme une nécessité
collègue aujourd'hui nous pouvons tenir
le fil de l'histoire le vote de ce texte
sera je l'espère une forme d'hommage à
leur juste combat je vous remercie
merci Madame la rapporteur
la parole est à monsieur Éric
Dupont-Moretti garde des sceaux ministre
de la justice
[Applaudissements]
présidente monsieur le président de la
commission des lois
madame
la présidente mesdames messieurs les
députés
après le débat au Sénat le mois dernier
c'est l'Assemblée nationale qui examine
aujourd'hui
une proposition de loi constitutionnelle
déposée par madame la Présidente pano
visant à protéger et à garantir le droit
fondamental à l'interruption volontaire
de grossesse
laissez-moi vous dire en préambule
que j'en suis heureux car le 13 juillet
dernier j'avais selon nelman déclaré
devant cette assemblée qu'en tant que
garde des sceaux je soutiendrai toutes
les initiatives parlementaires qui
viseraient à
constitutionnaliser le droit à l'IVG
[Applaudissements]
le voici donc au rendez-vous pour dire à
cette assemblée comme je l'ai dit au
Sénat modernier que le Gouvernement est
favorable à l'inscription du droit à
l'IVG dans notre Constitution
l'histoire fourmille d'exemples de
liberté fondamentale que l'on croyait
acquise et qui pourtant ont été rayés
d'un trait de plumes par les événements
les crises ou les lames de fonds
et c'est encore plus vrai lorsqu'il
s'agit des droits des femmes parce que
nos sociétés les ont en réalité bafoués
durant des siècles
les événements qui se déroulent hors de
nos frontières
partout dans le monde
nous le démontre avec force et acuité
c'est ce que nous rappelle la décision
de la Cour suprême des États-Unis de
juin dernier le droit à l'avortement
qu'on croyait à qui depuis 50 ans
ne l'était en réalité pas du tout
désormais l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse
n'est plus qu'un droit
n'est plus un droit garanti par la
Constitution fédérale des états
et les États fédérés sont donc libres de
l'interdire et pour certains d'entre eux
ils ne se prive pas de le faire
parce que nous avons en effet désormais
la preuve que
j'ai aucune démocratie
pas même l'une des plus grandes d'entre
toutes n'est à l'abri il nous faut
rester évidemment toujours
particulièrement vigilant
les auteurs de la présente proposition
de loi madame la Présidente panot
propose d'inscrire le droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
dans notre Constitution et j'entends
déjà
murmuré dans un premier temps
et puis s'élever des voix pour dire que
l'exemple américain n'est pas
transposable en France parce que le
droit à l'IVG y est bien protégé il est
vrai que nos institutions fonctionnent
différemment et que le Conseil
constitutionnel français n'est pas la
Cour suprême américaine il est vrai
aussi que le droit à l'IVG a été
conforté au fil des ans depuis qu'il a
été consacré pour la première fois dans
notre droit par la loi Veil du 17
janvier 1975
je pense ici à la dernière loi en date
du 2 mars 2022 porté par votre ancienne
collègue Albane Gaillot qui a allongé le
délai légal pour recourir à l'IVG on le
portant de 12 à 14 semaines je pense
aussi aux lois qui ont précédé comme par
exemple la loi du 4 août 2014 pour
l'égalité réelle entre les hommes et les
femmes qui a supprimé le critère de la
situation en détresse ou encore avant la
loi dite neyers du 27 janvier
1993 qui a dépénalisé l'auto avortement
est créé le délit d'entrave à l'IVG
pour autant
vous le savez gravé dans le marbre de
notre Constitution le droit fondamental
à l'IVG me paraît plus que nécessaire en
ces temps agités d'abord
cette inscription aurait une valeur
symbolique et bien sûr également
juridique
la constitution et le texte fondateur de
notre État de droit le socle commun des
valeurs et des libertés fondamentales de
notre société inscrire l'IVG dans notre
texte fondamental permettrait de
consacrer comme un droit fondamental et
non simplement comme une liberté
autonomie ensuite
parce qu'il faut bien convenir de cette
évidence changer la constitution et
beaucoup plus difficile que changer la
loi aujourd'hui protéger au niveau
législatif le droit à l'IVG sera demain
protéger au niveau constitutionnel cela
signifie que le législateur ne pourra
pas le remettre
substantiellement en cause seul le
pouvoir constituant le pourrait la
démocratie
l'État de droit et les droits
fondamentaux sont des biens précieux il
est de notre devoir de les préserver
alors ne prenons pas de risques et
protégeons le droit à l'IVG
que le droit à l'avortement largement
partagé au sein de l'Union européenne à
toutefois et vous l'avez rappelé madame
la Présidente panot était récemment
remis en question par plusieurs de nos
voisins européens
en Hongrie
par exemple
les femmes ne peuvent plus avorter
sans avoir préalablement dû écouter le
battement de cœur du fœtus
certes il met difficile bien sûr de me
mettre à la place des femmes qui
subissent cela mais je voudrais qu'on
s'arrête un instant
dans le silence et le recueillement
peut-être sur la violence inouïe qu'une
telle obligation
inflige aux femmes hongroises
je le dis tout net tant que je serai
garde des sceaux et tant que cette
majorité gouvernera notre pays nous ne
permettrons jamais qu'une telle violence
soit imposée aux femmes françaises
[Applaudissements]
l'avenir
Chari pourtant sa part d'incertitude
c'est pourquoi nous voulons
constitutionnaliser ce droit
d'autant qu'il ne fait d'ailleurs
l'objet d'aucune harmonisation dans
l'Union européenne en effet le président
de la République a lancé vous le savez
en janvier dernier le chantier ambitieux
mais au combien nécessaire de
l'inscription du droit à l'IVG au sein
de la Charte des droits fondamentaux de
l'Union européenne pour que l'Europe
qui nous a déjà apporté la paix apporte
au droit des femmes la protection
qu'elle mérite
mesdames messieurs les députés
ne vous trompez pas inscrire aujourd'hui
le droit à l'IVG dans notre Constitution
n'est pas une mesure gadget
un artifice de communication ou un
mouvement de panique face à un exemple
lointain
inscrire le droit à l'IVG cette liberté
fondamentale et inaliénable de la femme
c'est une sécurité pour toutes les
femmes de notre pays les temps troublés
et les remous ne sont jamais loin dans
le frêle esquif de la démocratie
faites en sorte que nous nous
la montillons pas de ne pas avoir
sauvegardé aujourd'hui ce droit
fondamental qui pourrait être remise en
cause demain mais que les choses soient
claires il ne s'agit pas là d'une
entreprise aisée je le dis avec gravité
on ne doit toucher à la constitution que
d'une main tremblante c'est pourquoi
il nous faut avoir à l'esprit que la
rédaction que vous retiendrez
aujourd'hui
lundi prochain ou lors des prochains
débats sera évidemment
déterminante une rédaction inadaptée
pour être en effet
conduire soit à consacrer un accès
absolument sans conditions à l'IVG je
pense par exemple à des IVG bien au-delà
de la limite légale en vigueur
une écriture mal soupeée pourrait
également s'avérer trop rigide et
empêcher une adaptation possible du
dispositif actuel si celle-ci s'avérait
nécessaire comme cela a déjà été le cas
au mois de mars dernier
il nous faudra alors au cours des débats
restés très vigilants sur ces possibles
effets de bord il nous faudra également
rester vigilant sur le choix de la place
à laquelle inscrire le droit à l'IVG
dans la Constitution afin de donner tout
son sens à cette reconnaissance et toute
sa cohérence au regard des autres
dispositions constitutionnelles
par ailleurs je ne veux pas ternir votre
notre enthousiasme votre enthousiasme
il nous faut désormais tenir compte du
vote du Sénat du 19 octobre dernier
car oui car oui modifier la Constitution
nécessite que la proposition de révision
soit adaptée je le rappelle dans des
termes
identiques dans les deux chambres or les
sénateurs ont rejeté d'emblée la
proposition de la sénatrice Mélanie
Vogel qui ressemblait peu ou proue à la
version dont nous débattrons aujourd'hui
je sais que de nombreux amendements vont
être débattus et c'est le rôle du
Parlement que d'affiner bien sûr les
textes qu'il examinent toutefois je me
dois de rappeler ce principe de réalité
mener à bout ce chantier historique
nécessite de prendre en compte
toutes les contraintes politiques en
présence dans les deux chambres c'est
pourquoi
je le dis sans embage je suis réservé
sur l'écriture actuelle qui n'a à mon
sens quasiment aucune chance d'aboutir
au regard de mes discussions au Sénat le
moins dernier
si je me réjouis
que votre commission des Lois est quant
à elle adoptait deux textes
je peux vous dire d'emblée que la
commission des Lois du Sénat n'a pas
accepté un texte qui
constitutionnaliserait également l'accès
à la contraception c'est pourquoi
conformément à mon engagement et aux
déclarations fortes de la première
ministre je soutiendrai les propositions
qui se concentrent sur l'IVG car la
Constitution ne peut se modifier en
laissant de côté l'une des deux champs
si nous voulons donner à ce chantier
commun toutes les chances d'aboutir il
nous faut faire preuve mesdames et
messieurs de réalisme sur ce point
l'écriture actuelle de la proposition de
loi de la présidente berger et de votre
collègue Marie-Pierre ricin nous semble
plus à même d'aboutir
mais j'ai noté madame la Présidente
panneau
que des amendements avaient été déposés
en ce sens je les lis avec sagesse
toutefois la rédaction
idoine à la fois ambitieuse et calibrée
à la fois fidèle à l'esprit de notre
Constitution et fidèle à notre ambition
reste encore à dénicher c'est pourquoi
le travail du Parlement doit se
poursuivre ainsi que l'indiquer le
président de la République la semaine
dernière
je veux d'ailleurs saluer
de manière républicaine l'ensemble des
initiatives qui se sont faites jour dans
les deux chambres qu'elles émanent de
l'opposition ou de la majorité
je vous livre le fond de ma pensée
je reste optimiste car le Sénat n'a
rejeté le texte que de 17 voix il n'a
donc manqué que 17 voix
pour ce que je considère être un échec
porteur d'espoir
mais si j'ose dire le Sénat a lui
assumer son vote de rejet
tout en se montrant
particulièrement ouvert au dialogue
ce que je constate avec tristesse
c'est que sur un sujet aussi grave que
celui-là
on puisse au fond se livrer à ce petit
jeu d'obstruction parlementaire
et si vous voulez que
je vous dise
j'observe
que
ce sont les mêmes
qui nous disent qu'il ne faut soit
disant pas importer les débats
américains en France qui en fait
importe les pires méthodes américaines
avec ce matin une mauvaise leçon de
Philippe bustering
en bon français naturellement
acheter un dictionnaire franco-anglais
vous verrez c'est une expression
utilise c'est une c'est une expression
c'est une expression parce que je peux
vous le traduire en russe aussi si vous
voulez
[Applaudissements]
la nuit dernière ce sont encore la nuit
dernière ce sont encore vous allez
comprendre des dizaines des dizaines
d'amendements de sous amendements qui
ont été déposés
sans répit
et ce alors même que le sujet qui nous
réunit ce matin
particulièrement important
particulièrement gras de quoi
parlons-nous nous parlons du droit des
femmes à disposer de leur corps le droit
à l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
est une condition indispensable à
l'émancipation des femmes sans laquelle
l'égalité
principe absolument cardinal de notre
République en vertu de l'article 2 de la
Constitution ne saurait être pleinement
respecté je le répète pour ce messieurs
dames qui produisent des amendements
comme en produirait des gravillons pour
gripper la machine la volonté politique
est là le Gouvernement est favorable à
l'inscription de l'IVG dans la
Constitution
l'Assemblée nationale je l'espère sera
favorable à l'IVG dans la Constitution
et je ne perds pas espoir avec un
dialogue nourri
et un travail approfondi le Sénat sera
peut-être favorable à l'IVG dans la
Constitution c'est pourquoi je vous le
dis à tous
comme je l'ai dit à vos collègues
sénateurs le mois dernier travaillons
encore cheminons ensemble afin de mener
à bien cette réforme historique pour
dire avec la plus grande force qui soit
aux générations actuelles et futures de
françaises mesdames votre corps vous
appartient pointe à la ligne
merci monsieur le garde des sceaux nous
en revenons à la discussion générale
madame Pascal Martin pour le groupe la
France insoumise nups pour une durée ne
pouvant excéder 10 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur collègue
commençons par un petit problème
arithmétique
sachant que sur les 577 sièges que
compte cette émission 215 sont occupés
par des femmes sachant qu'en France une
femme sur trois avorte au cours de sa
vie combien de femmes qui vont voter
aujourd'hui pour ou contre notre
proposition de loi ont recours ou vont
avoir recours à l'avortement
la réponse est 71
71 femmes parmi nous ont avorté ou
avorteront
si j'avais un peu plus de temps devant
moi je pourrais vous donner des
estimations plus précises par groupe
politique
au sein du groupe rassemblement national
par exemple on trouve 33 femmes on peut
donc estimer qu'environ 11 d'entre elles
ont avorté ou avorteront un jour
car oui les femmes de droite avortent
aussi y compris celles dont les amis
parlent de l'avortement comme d'un
génocide y compris celles dont les
principes religieux interdisent cet acte
parce que quand on se retrouve face à
une perspective aussi vertigineuse que
celle de devenir mère lorsqu'on ne le
désire pas on n'est plus guidé par des
principes ou des croyances en
particulier on est guidé par des
aspirations humaines que nous partageons
toutes et tous la volonté de choisir
notre propre vie de vivre dignement
l'avortement est crucial pour les femmes
la preuve c'est qu'elles sont tout aussi
nombreuses à avorter lorsque l'IVG est
interdite elles sont donc prêtes à
mettre leur santé voir leur vie en
danger en pratiquant des IVG
clandestines non sécurisées on estime
qu'avant la loi veille environ 250
femmes mouraient chaque année en France
des suites d'un avortement celle qui ne
mourraient pas été nombreuses à souffrir
de conséquences graves sur leur santé
des septicémies des hémorragies voire
parfois la stérilité définitive celle
qui ne parvenait pas à avorter quant à
elle pouvait voir leur vie entièrement
bouleversée et parfois détruite
c'est pour ces raisons que nous nous
battons aujourd'hui pour assurer une
meilleure protection juridique au droit
à l'avortement ainsi qu'à la
contraception
tout ça pour dire que parmi les femmes
qui aujourd'hui voteront contre une
meilleure protection du droit à l'IVG un
certain nombre ont sans doute elle-même
avorté mais assez parlé des femmes
parlons un peu des hommes ici présents
combien d'entre vous collecte de droite
avaient une compagne ou une ex-compagne
qui a pratiqué une IVG
combien d'entre vous avez une fille à la
maison et serait bien content qu'elle
puisse accéder librement à l'avortement
le jour où elle en aura besoin
en fait en écoutant les débats qui
entourent cette question depuis quelques
mois je suis frappé par une certaine
hypocrisie
l'hypocrisie de ces députés qui sont
prêts à voter contre une meilleure
garantie du droit à l'IVG simplement
parce qu'ils aient elle savent très bien
que si ce droit est un jour menacé ce ne
sont pas eux ni leurs proches qui auront
à en subir les conséquences
ils savent très bien qu'il leur suffira
de payer une certaine somme ou de
prendre un billet d'avion pour
l'étranger et le problème sera réglé
l'hypocrisie aussi de ces députés qui
aux affirmer encore et encore que le
droit à l'IVG n'est pas menacé en France
qu'aucun parti politique ne souhaite y
attaquer que nous importons un débat qui
serait totalement étranger à la France
et pendant ce temps nous recevons à
l'Assemblée mes collègues et moi un
courrier d'une organisation anti VG qui
nous explique avorter est un crime avec
un fœtus en silicone ce sont l'un des
méthodes et une rhétorique qui n'ont
rien à envier au mouvement provient
américain
cette même organisation anti VG a
organisé hier soir une conférence au
Parlement européen à Strasbourg sur le
thème s'opposer à l'IVG en Europe et aux
États-Unis comment aller de l'avant au
Parlement européen et monsieur le
ministre vient d'en parler ici même à
l'Assemblée nous avons un groupe de 89
députés dont plusieurs membres se sont
exprimés au fil des années et jusqu'à
récemment contre l'avortement certains
d'entre vous avaient qualifié l'IVG de
génocide avait appelé à son
déremboursement d'autres parmi vous ont
même affirmé qu'ils sont pour
labrogation de ce droit si ils arrivent
un jour au pouvoir
mais bien sûr aujourd'hui devant nous
vous ne tenez pas le même discours vous
avancez toutes sortes de raisons
techniques et juridiques pour voter
contre cette loi madame la Présidente
panneau a très bien expliqué que vos
arguments ne sont pas valables nous
savons toutes et tous que la vraie
raison pour laquelle vous vous y opposez
c'est que vous êtes contre l'IVG
d'ailleurs les innombrables amendements
d'obstruction que vous avez déposées le
montre très bien votre but n'est pas
d'améliorer notre loi votre but est
simplement d'empêcher qu'elle soit votée
et même débattus
vous semblez vous être bien amusé en
rédigeant certains amendements vous
proposez de remplacer ou compléter le
texte de notre loi par des articles qui
n'ont aucun rapport des articles sur la
PMA sur les droits des étrangers vous
proposez de changer le titre de notre
loi en proposition de loi
constitutionnelle visant à laisser
croire que l'IVG serait remise en cause
en France
la capacité des femmes à disposer
librement de leur corps et de leur vie
n'est-elle qu'un jeu pour vous
je ne vous pose pas cette question à la
légère vous savez je vais vous lire le
témoignage de Josette une femme de
Dordogne qui m'a raconté son histoire
c'était en 1960 j'avais 14 ans un soir
ma maman dans la baignoire toute pâle
elle avait 36 ans je me rappellerai
toujours son regard apeuré mon père a
appelé une ambulance et c'est la
dernière fois que j'ai vu ma mère elle
est décédée trois semaines plus tard à
l'hôpital de Strasbourg à l'époque je ne
comprenais pas j'avais 14 ans on m'a
juste dit qu'elle était morte d'une
septicémie j'ai été obligée de quitter
l'école et de m'occuper de mes cinq
frères et sœurs jusqu'à mes 20 ans
ce n'est qu'à 20 ans en discutant avec
ma tante que j'ai compris que ma mère
était décédée d'un avortement à l'époque
évidemment c'était interdit d'avorter
elle l'avait fait toute seule avec les
moyens du bord ma mère a eu 6 enfants et
j'ai appris plus tard que ce n'était pas
la première fois qu'elle avait tenté
d'avorter elle devait avoir peur à
chaque rapport peur de tomber enceinte
d'autant que mon père se mettait en
colère contre elle à chaque fois que ça
arrivait
ses souvenirs restent extrêmement
douloureux pour moi ce sont des
traumatismes qui restent ce sont des
vies qui sont détruites ou bouleversées
à cause des avortements clandestins
celle de ma mère évidemment mais aussi
la mienne celle de mes frères et soeurs
et celle de mon père je raconte cette
histoire parce que ma colère doit servir
à quelque chose aujourd'hui encore je
suis enragée quand j'entends des gens
dire qu'ils sont contre l'avortement ou
qu'ils veulent limiter ce droit la
maternité ça doit rester son choix
alors comme Joseph je m'adresse aux
collègues qui s'opposent à l'inscription
de l'IVG de la contraception dans la
Constitution vous savez moi sur ce sujet
je ne peux pas parler avec autant de
détachement et d'assurance que vous je
ne parviens pas à mettre de côté tous
les signaux d'alerte qui nous poussent
mes collègues et moi à vouloir mieux
protéger notre accès à l'IVG contre les
soubresauts électoraux oui nous avons
peur de voir revenir un temps où nous
serons à nouveau contraintes de mettre
notre vie en danger pour avorter un
temps où les hommes pourront à nouveau
décider de nos propres destins
pensez-vous vraiment que notre
inquiétude ne mérite pas d'être prise au
sérieux alors même que les femmes de
tant de pays autour de nous sont en
train de vivre précisément ce que nous
craignons qu'avez-vous peur de perdre en
votant une proposition de loi qui
entraînera une protection plus forte de
nos droits
d'autant qu'en votant contre notre PPLC
vous allez contre la volonté des
Françaises et des Français
87% d'entre eux se sont prononcés en
faveur de l'inscription du droit à
l'avortement dans la Constitution
87% et ce chiffre ne change quasiment
pas selon l'appartenance politique les
électeurs électriques du rassemblement
national et des républicains sont tout
aussi favorables à cette mesure que les
électeurs électriques de gauche tous les
groupes politiques qui défendent
globalement l'IVG et les droits des
femmes ont déclaré qu'il voteraient
notre PPLC bien entendu certains ont
émis des réserves ils ont déposé des
amendements mais il la voteront quant à
vous qui cherchez à tout faire pour
qu'elle ne passe pas vous qui osez vous
présenter contre comme favorable au
droit à l'IVG alors même que vous vous
opposez à une mesure qui permettrait
simplement de mieux protéger ce droit
sachez que nous ne sommes pas dupe la
droite conservatrice réactionnaire et
misogyne opposées aux droits des femmes
va montrer son vrai visage aujourd'hui
et les femmes de France vous regardent
merci de comprendre
la
parole est à Monsieur Laurent Pagny fou
pour le groupe liberté indépendant
outre-mer et territoire pour une durée
ne pouvant excéder cinq minutes
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la rapporteur mes chers
collègues les avancées consacrées par la
loi veille il y a 47 ans sont désormais
acceptés par une immense majorité de nos
concitoyens ce texte a traversé les âges
pour protéger les droits des femmes dans
tous nos territoires
la question nous est donc posée
aujourd'hui sur la possibilité d'aller
plus loin et d'inscrire le droit à
l'accès à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse et à la contraception dans
notre Constitution
je m'exprime ici à mon nom et celui
d'une partie des députés de mon groupe
nous y sommes en effet libre de nos
votes
comme beaucoup de mes collègues je tiens
à rendre hommage au combat mené par
Simone Veil en 1975 ce combat pour le
droit des femmes est entré dans
l'histoire mais reste d'actualité il ne
tient qu'à nous de le prolonger et de le
consacrer solennellement dans notre
norme la plus élevée
les Françaises nous écoutent avec une
attention particulière aujourd'hui
j'aimerais d'abord répondre à ce qui
laisse entendre que nous serions
suffisamment protégés en France qui
n'est nul besoin de sécuriser l'IVG je
leur dirai que l'optimisme est une
qualité mais qu'elle ne doit pas mener à
l'aveuglement
la loi veille est une garantie
essentielle pour le droit à l'IVG mais
ce droit reste dans la loi ordinaire une
autre loi pourrait le limiter le
restreindre est revenir sur ses acquis
il peut également y avoir des
revirements jurisprudentiels conduisant
à des décisions inattendues que ce soit
dans le bon sens mais aussi dans le
mauvais
inutile d'aller jusqu'aux États-Unis
pour trouver des exemples inquiétants on
en trouve déjà ici parmi les pays
membres de l'Union européenne en Pologne
c'est le Tribunal constitutionnel qui a
réduit de manière drastique l'accès à
l'avortement à rebours de l'équilibre
juridique qu'il avait trouvé dans les
années 90
le gouvernement portugais a quant à lui
décider en 2015 de mettre à la charge
des femmes tous les fraisiers à l'arrêt
de leur grossesse un Espagne un projet
de loi approuvé en 2013 en conseil des
ministres prévoyez de limiter l'IVG au
cas de graves danger pour la vie la
santé physique oblige psychologique de
la mer ou de viol avant d'être retiré
devant le tolé suscité dans notre pays
il existe aussi certains organismes
militants contre la protection de l'IVG
souvenez-vous qu'il n'y a pas si
longtemps en janvier 2020 une campagne
antivégée avait été affichée dans les
espaces publicitaires du métro de notre
capital
c'est vrai pour l'instant en France
aucun mouvement politique d'ampleur ne
demande l'abolition pure et simple du
droit à l'IVG est-ce pour cela qu'il
faudrait ne rien faire
devrions-nous rester les bras croisés
sous prétexte que le danger de voir ce
droit à moins de riz n'est pas encore
devant la porte de notre assemblée je
crois au contraire que nous devons agir
pendant que nous le pouvons tant qu'une
majorité d'entre nous est contre tout
recule sur ce droit ce que je veux dire
à cette hémicycle c'est que l'improbable
n'est pas impossible et que c'est le
rôle d'un élu d'un représentant de la
nation d'anticiper et d'agir même face à
ce qui est aujourd'hui considéré comme
hautement incertain ne prenons pas de
risque ne parions pas sur un sujet aussi
important
le droit à l'IVG fait pleinement partie
de notre contrat social les droits des
femmes sont des droits fondamentaux
l'IVG méritent d'être inscrit au sein de
notre Constitution
à ceux qui disent que nous sommes dans
le symbole je veux dire qui ne s'agit
aucunement de faire semblant mais de
renforcer une protection ordinaire pour
lui offrir un bouclier constitutionnel à
la hauteur des enjeux certes lorsqu'il
prend sa plume pour réviser la
Constitution le législateur doit agir
avec prudence mais le droit à l'IVG est
une flamme qu'il faut entretenir si nous
ne voulons pas un jour le voir régresser
au point de s'éteindre comme c'est le
cas dans de trop nombreux pays du monde
cette consécration d'un droit effectif
inclus dans cette proposition de loi
devra également se traduire concrètement
dans les territoires pour assurer à
toutes les femmes le droit à l'accès à
l'IVG en particulier dans les zones
rurales où la cartographie médicale et
le manque de moyens sont trop souvent
des obstacles mes chers collègues
aujourd'hui je fais le choix de
renforcer les acquis de la loi veille et
de parer un avenir incertain en actant
cette consécration au rang
constitutionnelle je voterai pour cette
proposition de loi
merci merci monsieur le député
la parole est à Monsieur
Erwan Balanant pour le groupe démocrate
Monet mais indépendant pour une durée ne
pouvant excéder cinq minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés mes chers
collègues monsieur le garde des sceaux
le 24 juin dernier la Cour suprême des
États-Unis en annulant l'arrêt versus
Waze Wade qui reconnaissait le droit à
l'avortement dans l'ensemble des États
fédérés après une décision lourde de
sens et lourde de conséquences
ce volte-face historique de la
juridiction suprême américaine conduit à
ce que la population américaine se voit
aujourd'hui privé petit à petit de l'un
de leurs droits fondamentaux celui de
disposer en conscience et librement de
leur corps
l'onde de choc de cette régression
historique bouleverse nos convictions et
brise le mouvement que l'on croyait
continu des progrès des femmes à
disposer de leur corps ce séisme
politique outre-Atlantique nous
contraint à nous interroger sur notre
capacité à anticiper de tels revers en
France et en Europe
alors pour commencer rappelons que cette
décision n'emporte effectivement aucune
conséquence juridique sur notre
continent mais elle nous permet pourtant
de constater que si l'IVG est autorisé
dans la majeure partie de l'Union son
accès y est parfois en travers
le constat est regrettable le droit
d'avorter est toujours lui fragilisé sur
notre continent
ces situations nous obligent à repenser
les garanties offertes par notre droit
oui en France l'accès à l'IVG est
garanti par la loi veille oui la
juridiction constitutionnelle la
considéré comme conforme à la
Constitution oui notre bloc de
constitutionnalité en particulier
l'article 2 de la Déclaration des droits
de l'homme et du citoyen de 1789
reconnaît la liberté de la femme oui la
loi du 2 mars 2022 est venu renforcer
l'accès aux droits en portant à 14
semaines de grossesse le délai de
recours à l'IVG
il faut heureusement aucun parti
politique français n'a verbalisé à ce
jour à ce jour son souhait de revenir
sur la loi veille
mais devons-nous nous accommoder de cet
état de fête au motif que notre
Constitution n'aurait pas de vocation à
cataloguer des droits individuels
quelle difficulté y aurait-il à
renforcer en ces temps troubles les
gages donnés à la préservation des
droits reproductifs et sexuelle des
femmes
rappelant que si nous débattons
aujourd'hui c'est que justement ce droit
à l'IVG ne bénéficie pas de la
protection la plus forte qui soit son
inscription dans notre norme suprême la
Constitution
or une quasi uneanimité se dessine
aujourd'hui tant chez nos concitoyens
que sur notre échiquier politique les
Français la société française le veut 8
Français sur 10 se disent y être
favorables les bandes de notre émission
le veulent de tout bord ou presque
chacun chaque groupe politique a
manifesté son adhésion à cette
constitutionnalisation alors j'insiste
sur le mot presque car le nombre
d'amendements déposés par certains me
permettent de soupçonner une forme
d'obstruction où l'expression d'une
opposition peu subtile tout en essayant
de sauver les apparences
revenons à notre sujet
en ces temps de la nécessaire protection
des droits des femmes et du renforcement
de l'égalité famom la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG serait
un message
fort un signal fort et utile au reste du
monde car à ce jour aucune constitution
ne reconnaît ce droit de façon positive
or si nous attend que nous avons un
consensus pour réviser la Constitution
cela ne doit pas se faire à la légère
vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le garde
des sceaux
le dispositif retenu par la présente
proposition nous paraît répondre aux
principales objectifs de consécration
constitutionnelle du droit à l'IVG mais
l'écriture proposée à notre hémicycle ce
jour à ce jour n'est pas à ce stade
encore complètement satisfaisante et
Madame la rapporteur vous le concevez
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous vous
soumettrons aujourd'hui une écriture
différente fruit d'un travail collectif
et transpartisan que je tiens à saluer
et je salue madame la rapporteur
Mathilde panot au-delà de nos vies
divergence politique cet amendement que
nous vous proposons prouve que nous
avons su avancer ensemble sur un sujet
sociétal majeur
cette nouvelle écriture est plus
protectrice des droits que nous
cherchons à proposer par une formulation
positive nous reconnaissons un droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
et nous procédons un principe intangible
dans la Constitution en renvoyant à la
loi le soin d'un garantir l'effectivité
et les galaxies en d'autres termes cette
rédaction consacre consacre à la fois le
caractère fondamental de ce droit et la
nécessité de son encadrement par la loi
mais aussi un principe de non régression
à la matière qui emporterait
l'inconstitutionnalité de tout
dispositif législatif qui viendrait
porter atteinte à l'exercice de ce droit
je conclus ma chère collègue mon groupe
souhaite également retirer la
contraception des dispositifs proposés
et ainsi elle votera ce texte merci
monsieur le député
la parole est à Madame Marie-Noëlle
Battistel pour le groupe socialiste et
apparenté pour une durée ne pouvant
excéder 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le garde
des sceaux madame la rapporteur chers
collègue 5 c'est le nombre d'initiatives
parlementaires qui t'ont été prises ces
derniers mois pour inscrire le droit à
l'IVG dans la Constitution 2 ce sont
celles qui ont été adoptées par
l'Assemblée nationale en commission ces
15 derniers jours et 81 c'est le
pourcentage des Français et des
françaises qui sont favorables à
l'inscription du droit dans la
Constitution ces chiffres démontent bien
le consensus autour de l'importance et
de l'urgence à constitutionnaliser le
droit à l'IVG à ce titre je remercie la
rapporteur Mathilde panot pour ses
travaux et ses méthodes collectives pour
parvenir à la version la plus
consensuelle possible je salue également
notre collègue Aurore berger pour sa
proposition ainsi que Guillaume
gouffiercha pour notre collaboration au
nom de la délégation aux droits des
femmes sans surprise je soutiens toutes
ces initiatives qui convergent et
chemine vers le même objectif comme la
proposition que nous avons déposée avec
ma collègue Cécile intermeyer alors que
le 24 juin dernier la Cour suprême
américaine ouvrait la possibilité de
restreindre ou d'interdire le droit à
l'avortement alors que sur notre propre
continent les atteintes à l'IVG se
multiplient la Pologne qui a récemment
interdit l'avortement quand Malte ne l'a
jamais autorisé la Hongrie qui contraint
désormais les femmes à écouter le cœur
tuetus avant de procéder à l'IVG le
Portugal qui demande à nouveau
l'autorisation parentale pour les jeunes
filles mineures et l'Italie qui laisse
peu de doutes sur ses intentions à venir
bafouer ce droit
alors donc que les entraves au droit à
l'avortement sont prégnantes et
menaçantes la constitutionnalisation de
l'IVG devient un enjeu majeur pour le
droit des femmes si en France
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de menace
directe au droit à l'IVG les exemples
cités à l'instant démontrent bien qu'il
faut se garder de toutes illusion sur ce
qu'il pourrait advenir et c'est bien le
rôle du droit constitutionnel de
prévenir de telles atteintes l'absence
actuelle de remise en cause de
l'avortement dans notre pays constituent
précisément la raison pour laquelle il
doit être constitué dès maintenant dès
lors que le droit fondamental serait
inscrit dans la Constitution il serait
protégé d'initiative politique qui
souhaiteraient lui porter atteinte son
inscription permettrait également de
faire progresser sa protection réelle
notamment en matière d'accès au service
de santé enfin en étant la première
inscrire ce droit dans la Constitution
la France confirmerait son attachement
au droit des femmes et enverrai un
message fort aux autres pays
je tiens à rappeler que mon groupe
demande une telle consécration depuis la
réforme constitutionnelle de 2018 et que
nous avons déposé une première
proposition de loi en juin 2019 mais
c'est multiples initiatives aussi
positives qu'elles soient ne doivent pas
pour autant nous permettre nous perdre
dans des débats sémantiques et nous
éloigner de l'objectif commun de
parvenir à une inscription dans la
Constitution c'est le sens de la
communication que j'ai présenté à la
délégation droit des femmes jeudi
dernier avec mon collègue Gouffier chat
c'est pour cela aussi que nous avons
travaillé de manière transpartisante
avec la rapporteur à une proposition de
rédaction consensuelle autour des
différentes questions qui ont fait débat
ces deux dernières semaines il s'agit
d'inscrire à l'article 66 2 la loi
garantit l'effectivité et les galaxies
au droit à l'avortement
évidemment mon groupe soutiendra
d'autres versions plus ambitieuses comme
de prévoir également l'inscription du
droit à la contraception ou encore
d'inscrire ses droits à l'article
premier de la Constitution mais cette
version que nous vous proposons chers
collègues et celles qui nous semblent à
la fois respecter les exigences des
hommes et apaiser les inquiétudes des
autres elle nous permettrait de faire
tomber tous les amendements
d'obstruction habituels d'une partie de
la droite et de l'extrême droite et
d'envoyer le message fort que la nation
est prête à inscrire ce droit dans la
Constitution
enfin je terminerai par là j'appelle le
gouvernement monsieur le ministre à
reprendre cette version consensuelle
sous la forme d'un projet de loi car
vous le savez c'est le véhicule
législatif le plus adapté pour une
adoption du texte par le Parlement
réunion congrès quand on va aujourd'hui
comment quelques-uns parviennent à
obstruer le débat comme ils se sont suif
le faire à chaque fois qu'il était
question de protéger l'avortement dans
cette hémicycle on peut craindre qu'en
cas de référendum les mouvances
antichois seront suffisamment organisés
et financés pour mener une campagne de
désinformation sur le sujet nous ne
voulons pas d'un débat public nauséabond
et insultant à l'encontre de toutes les
femmes c'est pourquoi nous vous
demandons de reprendre cette proposition
dans un projet de loi que nous voterons
et nous comptons sur vous merci beaucoup
merci madame la députée
[Applaudissements]
la France pays de Simone Veil pays de la
liberté se doit d'être exemplaire
nous ne transigeons pas et ne
transigerons jamais avec le droit à
l'IVG
protéger ce droit ses protéger les
femmes
protéger la France contre un retour au
faiseuse d'ange aux avortements sur la
table d'une arrière cuisine qui laissait
des femmes mutilées humiliées ravagées
l'accès à l'IVG est aussi une question
de santé publique c'est s'assurer que
cet acte qui est toujours un drame pour
celles qui ont recours soient pratiqués
sans risque physique et psychique
le groupe horizon estime qu'il est
absolument nécessaire que ce droit
continue d'être protégé et renforcée il
faut que chacun d'entre nous
soit à chaque instant extrêmement
vigilant à ce que rien ne vienne le
restreindre d'aucune manière que ce soit
sa remise en cause même indirecte par la
Cour suprême des États-Unis est
absolument inacceptable
même si certains pays européens
attaquent droit il est plutôt rassurant
de constater qu'aujourd'hui la France
est dans une situation très éloignée de
celle des États-Unis notre réaction doit
être empreinte de mesure et de
tempérance
nous partageons l'idée que dans ce
contexte inscrire ce droit dans notre
Constitution est un symbole politique
fort envoyé aux femmes et aux hommes
français mais aussi au monde entier
nous nous sommes beaucoup interrogés sur
la permanence de cette réponse
réactionnelle émotionnelle il n'y
avait-il pas d'autres réponses à
apporter au sujet spécifique des
États-Unis
pour autant les débats en commission
nous ont éclairés et permis de nous
réjouir qu'un consensus sur le principe
même de la constitutionnalisation du
droit à l'IVG existe
ce consensus ne doit pas nous empêcher
de réfléchir à la meilleure manière de
l'inscrire dans notre Constitution bien
au contraire c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous souhaitons qu'il soit
précisé que c'est à la loi de garantir
l'effectivité à l'accès à l'IVG
cette nouvelle proposition de rédaction
apporte notre approbation car d'une part
inclure la contraception dans cette PPLC
ne nous semblait pas pertinente
d'autre part il permet de faire peser
sur le législateur la responsabilité
d'encadrer la loi étant sur les
conditions d'accès notamment en termes
de délai que sur la clause de conscience
des médecins c'est en effet à la
représentation nationale que doit
revenir le pouvoir d'organiser les
conditions dans lesquelles toute
personne peut avoir recours à l'IVG
le groupe horizon profondément attaché
au droit à l'IVG n'aura durant ce débat
qu'une seule boussole qui a aucun moment
le droit à l'IVG ne soit remise en cause
par quiconque
plus encore il nous appartient à tous de
veiller à l'équilibre défini par la loi
veille de le préserver chaque jour et
pour toutes les femmes
ce droit essentiel mérite de dépasser
les clivages politiques les prises
d'otages idéologiques voire caricaturale
cette constitutionnalisation ne doit
surtout pas occulter le travail qu'il
nous reste à fournir pour permettre
qu'effectivement toute personne qui en
fait la demande puis s'y recourir quel
que soit son âge quel que soit sa
situation géographique où sa situation
sociale
madame le rapporteur je tiens à
souligner la qualité de la collaboration
transpartisone dont nous avons pu
bénéficier vous avez tenu compte de nos
remarques sur la nouvelle rédaction et
nous en remercions
le groupe horizon votre a donc
favorablement à la
constitutionnalisation du droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
merci madame la députée la parole est à
Monsieur Jérémy jordanov pour les
groupes écologistes nupes pour une durée
ne pouvant excéder 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente
madame la rapporteur
monsieur le ministre chers collègues
le droit à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse a été acquis de haute lutte il
aura fallu attendre 1975 pour que
l'avortement soit ne serait-ce que
dépénalisé il faut croire que la liberté
des femmes à disposé de leur corps
n'allait pas de soi pour tout le monde
je veux rendre hommage aux femmes qui
ont pratiqué l'avortement clandestin au
mouvement de libération des femmes à
Simone Veil à toute seule toute celles
qui se battent en France et qui se
battent encore à travers le monde pour
faire reconnaître ce droit
la loi veille est une victoire pour
l'émancipation des femmes c'est une
révolution sur laquelle aujourd'hui
personne ne propose de revenir se débat
en France et trancher pour autant une
question se pose faut-il
constitutionnaliser le droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
il y a ça a été rappelé c'est très
inquiétant le contexte international
nous ne pouvons pas ignorer ce qui est
se passe aux États-Unis en Hongrie en
Pologne peut-être demain en Italie
la régression du droit ou de l'accès à
l'IVG est une dramatique réalité
à l'heure actuelle rien dans notre texte
fondamental ne protège directement le
droit à l'avortement et nous savons à
quel point la jurisprudence
constitutionnelle laisse au législateur
une grande latitude d'action
alors oui rehausser le niveau de
protection juridique de l'IVG n'est pas
un luxe
mais je veux surtout insister sur le
fond sur la possibilité de donner à un
principe la considération qui lui est
due il faut savoir reconnaître dans
l'IVG un droit fondamental tout
simplement
nous devons lui conférer une valeur
constitutionnelle parce que c'est un
principe qui a cette portée et parce
qu'il nous est cher
la liberté d'interrompre une grossesse
est une condition de l'égalité réelle
entre les femmes et les hommes il en va
de la plaine citoyenneté dans la même
logique nous pensons que le droit à la
contraception doit figurer figurer aussi
dans notre Constitution
chers collègues
nous avons une opportunité historique de
graver dans le marbre ce qui doit l'être
et par la même occasion de porter une
parole qui résonne au-delà de nos
frontières la France serait dans son
rôle si elle affirmait haut et fort que
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
est un droit fondamental il y a il
semble aujourd'hui dans cet assemblée
une majorité pour avancer dans cette
voie
même si je sais qu'il faudra convaincre
demain au Sénat
et je veux justement m'adresser
aujourd'hui aux républicains qui sont
sur nos bancs parce que je crois aux
vertus du débat parlementaire
les discussions ont été longues en
commission et les positions sont connues
ayez l'audace d'accepter une inscription
dans le texte principal à l'article
premier ou à minima au titre 8 la
rédaction qui vous est proposée
aujourd'hui par amendement
et succincte équilibrée elle vise à
garantir l'effectivité du droit dans son
état actuel ni plus ni moins il n'est
pas nécessaire d'agiter des peurs qui
n'existe pas j'appelle en conséquence et
les auteurs des amendements hors sujet
et des amendements qui ne sont que
mauvais prétexte aller retirer mesurer
mesurer les blessures que vous faites
aux femmes sur une matière aussi grave
partant d'obstruction parfois de
légèreté et surtout de mauvaise foi
je sais les pressions je sais les
pressions je connais les logiques
partisanes
mais je veux croire aussi
en la puissance que peuvent avoir dans
des moments déterminants
les convictions personnelles et le
courage
cette réforme constitutionnelle si nous
y arrivons sera l'aboutissement d'un
long et beau combat
sortons un instant des postures je vous
invite à adopter ce texte à une très
large majorité dans un esprit de
responsabilité de conviction et de
concorde je vous remercie
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
Madame Elsa fossillon pour le groupe
Bose démocrate et républicaine Lutèce
pour une durée ne pouvant excéder cinq
minutes
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la rapporteur chers
collègues pourquoi aujourd'hui
constitutionnaliser le droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
et bien d'abord parce que tout
simplement nous considérons qu'il est un
droit fondamental et qu'il faut le
consacrer comme tel ce sont nos corps
nos choix voilà ce que vous nous voulons
affirmer aujourd'hui avec cette
constitutionnalisation ce droit il a été
conquis de haute-lutte mais aussi dans
la douleur la douleur de toutes celles
qui ont avorté dans la clandestinité
celle qui en sont mortes il a été
conquis de haute lutte par des
militantes féministes qui ont été très
souvent menacé
et pour elle aujourd'hui nous voulons
aussi en leur mémoire en leur honneur
constitutionnaliser ce droit à l'IVG
nous pensons aussi
nous pensons aussi que
constitutionnaliser ce droit à
l'avortement et bien c'est participer à
lever le tabou qui entoure encore
aujourd'hui l'avortement
nous voulons le constitutionnaliser
parce qu'une femme qui veut avorter elle
avorte la maternité c'est un choix et
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui rend encore plus
beau cet acte nous voulons le
constitutionnaliser parce que nous
savons que les crises qui s'accumulent
dans nos sociétés et bien la faveur de
l'une d'entre elles ce droit peut-être
remis en cause nous voulons le
constitutionnaliser aussi parce qu'il ne
faut pas s'en cacher les attaques
répétées à l'encontre de ce droit sont
légion je vous cite les propos du forum
parlementaire européen pour les droits
sexuels et reproductifs qui nous disent
qu'entre 2009 et 2018 ce sont près de 86
milliards de dollars qui ont été
reversés au mouvement anti droit des
femmes et anti-avortement qui peut dire
ici qu'il n'y a pas de danger qui plane
sur le droit à l'interruption volontaire
de grossesse
nous le faisons aussi pour toutes ces
femmes plus vulnérables quant un droit
est menacé je cite à cette occasion les
propos tenus par Gisèle Halimi lors du
procès de Bobigny elle nous dit c'est
toujours la même classe celle des femmes
pauvres vulnérables économiquement et
socialement cette classe des sans argent
et des sans relation qui est frappé et
nous le savons quand ce droit est menacé
c'est d'abord les plus vulnérables
d'abord les plus pauvres qui sont en
danger c'est celle c'est bien d'elle
dans les corps sont en permanence en
danger enfin une dernière raison à cette
constitutionnalisation nous constatons y
compris dans notre pays combien
l'effectivité de ce droit est menacé
depuis 15 ans nous le rappelons 130
centres IVG ont été fermés et vu l'état
de notre santé publique dans le pays oui
ce droit l'effectivité de ce droit est
menacé
je veux m'adresser maintenant au député
qui ont clairement fait obstruction dans
les groupes LR et rassemblement national
qui ont crié un peu partout soit en
commission soit dans les médias que ils
étaient tout à fait favorables à ce
droit et qu'il n'y avait aucun danger
qui menaçait franchement à la lecture de
vos amendements comment peut-on croire
que ce droit n'est pas menacé dans notre
pays comment pourrait-on y croire
si ce n'est pas s'il n'y a pas de
mauvaise foi vous n'avez qu'à retiré ces
amendements pour permettre que nous
ayons un débat responsable rigoureux
plein de conviction vous avez encore la
possibilité de retirer ces amendements
donc oui vous nous confirmez qu'il
existe bel et bien un danger et vous
nous confirmez aussi qu'il faut
constitutionnaliser parce que le moment
est propice à le faire n'attendons pas
qu'il y ait danger pour graver dans le
marbre dans ce droit faisons-le
au collègue enfin des groupes
Renaissance horizon moderne
j'ai entendu pour ceux d'horizon et ceux
du MoDem qu'ils étaient favorables et je
veux les remercier car il y a eu un
travail fait par la reporter par la
rapporteur qui est important aux
collègues de renaissance faisons un
travail sérieux oui il faut en travail
rigoureux si nous voulons
constitutionnaliser mais je vous en
implore pas de jeu tactique pas de
tentative de leadership nos corps
méritent autre chose nos corps méritent
autre chose
alors oui nous ne faisons pas que
soutenir nous ne faisons pas que
soutenir cette proposition de loi nous
portons ce combat et nous espérons nous
espérons qu'il le sera par le plus grand
nombre aujourd'hui
merci madame la députée
la parole est à Madame Josiane Corneloup
pour le groupe les républicains pour une
durée ne pouvant excéder 5 minutes
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la rapporteur monsieur
le Président de la Commission mes chers
collègues aucune femme ne recourt de
gaîté de cœur à l'avortement il suffit
d'écouter les femmes voici les mots
prononcés par Simone Veil le 26 novembre
1974 48 ans après il raisonne toujours
en nous
l'interruption de volontaire de
grossesse est avant tout le combat des
femmes mais c'est aussi un combat de
toute notre société dans la
reconnaissance du droit des femmes à
disposer de leur corps rappelons que
jusqu'en janvier 1975 l'avortement
constituait un délit pénal sanctionné
par 50 prisons les médecins pouvaient
être condamnés à une interdiction
d'exercer et les femmes concernées
étaient contraintes de se rendre à
l'étranger ou de recourir à des
avortements clandestins
la reconnaissance de l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse a ainsi été le
fruit d'un long combat qui a commencé
grâce à notre famille politique on se
souvient du Manifeste des 343 ou de
l'acquittement de la jeune Marie-Claire
on se souvient aussi des débats au
Parlement d'une rare violence ou Simone
Veil soutenu par Jacques Chirac a
défendu son texte avec acharnement
malgré les attaques personnelles et
comme elle le soulignait si justement le
26 novembre 1974 ici devant l'Assemblée
nationale
l'avortement est toujours un drame et
cela restera toujours un drame depuis la
loi du 17 janvier
1975 la liberté d'interrompre sa
grossesse n'a cessé d'être conforté
depuis ce moment fondateur par cette
fois le législateur la renforcé avec la
suppression de la notion de détresse
l'allongement des délais d'avortement le
remboursement à 100% par la Sécurité
Sociale en 2001 où l'IVG est devenu un
véritable droit pour la femme et non
plus une simple dépénuse dépénalisation
aucun d'entre nous aujourd'hui
n'envisage de remettre en cause l'accès
à l'IVG
à l'heure où les Français sont touchés
par de multiples crises il apparaît tout
à fait décalé d'ouvrir un débat qui s'il
existe aux États-Unis n'existe pas en
France en circonscription mais
concitoyens me parlent du pouvoir
d'achat du coup de l'électricité du
carburant absolument pas de la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG ce n'est
pas parce qu'aux États-Unis en juin
dernier la Cour suprême révoquait
l'arrêtait qui garantissait le droit des
américaines à avorter qu'en France dans
la foulée nous devons avoir le même
débat or les deux PPL constitutionnels
tant celles déposées par la majorité que
par la France insoumise évoque toutes
deux la décision américaine dans leur
exposé des motifs
ce droit à l'IVG fait déjà l'objet d'une
protection constitutionnelle solide et
durable en France solide parce que l'IVG
figure dans notre droit depuis 1975
durable parce que le Conseil
constitutionnel l'a toujours jugé
conforme à la Constitution par quatre
fois il s'est prononcé en sa faveur en
1975 en 2001 en 2014 et en 2016 le
Conseil constitutionnel a attaché en
2001 l'IVG à la liberté personnelle de
la femme protégée par l'article 2 de la
Déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen de 1789
si la constitutionnalisation de la
reconnaissance de l'IVG doit intervenir
elle doit se faire avec la main
tremblante
c'est pour cela que nous portons un
amendement visant à constitutionnaliser
également les principes fondateurs de la
loiveille
le droit de la femme a demandé
l'interruption volontaire de sa
grossesse et le respect de tout être
humain dès le commencement de la vie
en proposant avec l'article unique de
cette proposition de loi d'inscrire dans
la Constitution que et je le cite nul ne
peut porter atteinte au droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
et à la contraception la loi garantit à
toute personne qui en fait la demande
l'accès libre et effectif à ses droits
les signataires de la prison proposition
de loi constitutionnelle modifierait en
profondeur l'équilibre de notre droit
tel qu'ici de la loi du 17 janvier 1975
en supprimant toutes les mesures
d'équilibre et de protection de l'enfant
à naître contenu dans cette loi
notamment le délai légal de l'IVG et le
recours à un médecin il y a donc un
véritable risque d'inscrire dans la
Constitution un droit à l'avortement
sans condition et jusqu'à la fin du
terme
aussi le présent amendement que je vous
invite à voter mes chers collègues vis à
ajouter la loi Veil au nombre des textes
fondamentaux auxquels le constituant
rappelle son attachement
enfin à tous ceux qui en commission des
lois on peut dire que on peut dire que
nous revenions à la loi stricto-sensuit
de 1975 je voudrais leur dire deux
choses la première c'est que vous
instrumentalisez ce texte pour être
perçu comme des progressistes en voulant
enfermer les autres dans des
contre-vérités insupportables
c'est d'éviter de multiples contentieux
sur les délais dirigés nous devrions me
semble-t-il nous intéresser au manque
d'information et de prévention qui est
obligé un certain nombre de femmes à
avoir recours à l'IVG notre groupe ne
donnera pas de consignes de vote je vous
remercie merci madame la députée la
parole est à Madame Sarah tanzili pour
le groupe renaissance pour une durée ne
pouvant excéder cinq minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le garde
des sceaux monsieur le président de la
commission des lois madame la rapporteur
panneau chers collègues
nous voici réunis aujourd'hui pour
examiner le premier des deux textes à
l'ordre du jour de notre assemblée qui
vise à garantir dans la Constitution le
droit à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse cette concomitance d'agenda
n'est pas le fruit du hasard elle
atteste d'une nécessité apparue à tous
les défenseurs des droits des femmes
celle de ce prémunir de tout de
régression de ses droits acquis de haute
lutte et qui sont non déplaise à
certains présents ici profondément et
gravement menacé car s'il est vrai que
le revirement de jurisprudence intervenu
aux États-Unis ne nous concerne pas
directement il nous renvoie au message
de Simone de Beauvoir
n'oubliez jamais qu'il suffira d'une
crise politique économique ou religieuse
pour que les droits des femmes soient
remis en question ces droits ne sont
jamais acquis d'ailleurs en Europe le
droit à l'IVG est aussi attaqué en
Pologne en Hongrie les coups de boutoirs
pleuvent et l'Italie de Mélanie risque
de prendre le même chemin régressif la
France serait-elle une île
imperméable aux théories réactionnaires
qui cible à chaque fois les droits des
femmes et en particulier le premier
d'entre eux celui de maîtriser son corps
et donc son destin
force et de constater que non la
propagande anti-avortement prospère sur
Internet et sur les réseaux sociaux
diffusé par des associations qui part
devant lèchent leur communication et par
derrière harcèle les élus qui portent
cette cause en leur envoyant des fœtus
en plastique des associations qui en
réalité considèrent que les femmes qui
avortent sont des meurtrières
elle prospère aussi ici comme on le
constate aujourd'hui avec les
amendements qui nous sont soumis on fait
du sabotage pour empêcher qu'une
majorité se dégage pour garantir le
droit à l'IVG on véhicule insidieusement
cette idée selon laquelle le droit à
l'IVG n'est pas vraiment un droit qu'il
s'appréhende comme un dispositif
dérogatoire qu'il s'agit d'une tolérance
et une tolérance on peut à tout moment y
mettre fin
l'enjeu vous l'aurez compris est fort il
est de protéger le droit de nos filles
et de nos petites filles à continuer à
maîtriser leur corps et leur vie face à
des mouvements réactionnaires agissant à
bas bruit mais bien présent en France
tant dans ses murs qu'en dehors il
s'agit aussi de faire de notre
République la première démocratie à
protéger dans sa constitution le droit à
l'IVG de positionner la France à
l'avant-garde du combat en faveur des
droits des femmes et d'envoyer un
message d'espoir à tous ceux et à toutes
celles qui mènent ce combat à travers le
monde
dans ce contexte vous comprendrez que la
détermination du groupe Renaissance a
conféré au droit à l'IVG la garantie la
plus forte que puisse offrir notre
hiérarchie des normes est totale c'est
pour cette raison quelle initiative
d'Aurore berger et de Marie-Pierre
rickson notamment notre groupe a déposé
dès le 30 juin dernier une proposition
de loi constitutionnelle
c'est aussi pour cette raison que notre
groupe votera en faveur de la
proposition qui nous est soumise ce jour
car ce texte
car ce texte mes chers collègues
car ce texte présente d'importantes
similitudes avec celui que notre groupe
a déposé comme notre texte il garantit
constitutionnellement le droit à l'IVG
comme notre texte il prévoit la création
d'un nouvel article 66 2 inscrit dans le
titre vide relatif à l'autorité
judiciaire gardienne de nos libertés
individuelles des différences sont
toutefois notables la rédaction proposée
aujourd'hui inclut le droit à la
contraception à l'instar de la PPLC
déposée par la sénatrice Vogel qui a été
rejetée le mois dernier par le Sénat
aussi il fait peu de doutes que ce texte
subirait le même destin funeste s'il
devait être soumis à l'examen de la
chambre haute de notre Parlement
différence notable mes chers collègues
c'est que chez Renaissance il n'y a pas
un discours de défense des droits des
femmes pour les Françaises et les
Français et un discours de protection et
de soutien à l'égard de ceux qui à vous
violenter les femmes quand il s'agit des
leaders du parti
ce combat ne souffre aucune
compromission et mes chers collègues de
LFI c'est pourtant ce que vous faites en
soutenant et on t'aimant Adrien cattyns
malgré
malgré ses réserves majeures malgré les
désaccords profonds et nombreux que nous
pouvons avoir avec la France insoumise
nous voterons cette proposition de loi
car face aux menaces face à cette
responsabilité forte pour nos filles et
nos petites filles pour les combattantes
et combattants féministes du monde
entier ce combat celui du droit des
femmes à disposer de son corps ne peut
souffrir aucun atermoiement ni aucune
considération partisane merci aussi
parce que nous sommes des blagues à
faire aboutir cette
constitutionnalisation que quel que soit
l'issue du texte qui nous est proposé ce
jour le groupe Renaissance portera
jusqu'à son terme laplc qui la déposé
très large majorité par la commission
des lois constitue le seul chemin qui
présente des choses sérieuses
d'anniversations
le droit à
merci madame la députée
la parole est à Madame Pascal borde pour
le groupe rassemblement national pour
une durée ne pouvant excéder 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le garde
des sceaux monsieur le président de la
commission des lois madame la rapporteur
l'idée d'afficher solennellement
au fronton de la République certains
principes dont un droit à l'IVG présente
un contestablement un attrait il n'en
reste pas moins excusez-moi madame la
députée excusez-moi seul madame bordel à
la parole merci de l'écouter dans le
silence s'il vous plaît
il n'en reste pas moins aussi séduisante
soit cette idée de prime abord que au
final cela pourrait avoir les effets
inverses de ce prétendument rechercher
avant toute chose le fait d'inscrire
dans la Constitution un droit à l'IVG ne
permettra pas de résoudre la question
majeure de l'effectivité de l'accès à
l'IVG l'urgence est à mon sens moins à
compléter la Constitution qu'à mettre
enfin en application les textes et
législatifs car près de 50 ans après la
loi veille nombreuse sont encore les
femmes désireuses d'avoir recours à une
IVG qui ne parviennent pas à le faire
dans de bonnes conditions ce heurtant
manque de médecins de sage-femmes trop
nombreuses trop nombreuses sont encore
les femmes qui sont contraintes face à
tous ces obstacles de quitter l'hexagone
pour aller subir une IVG dans des pays
beaucoup mieux organisés que le nôtre
sur toutes ces questions ce problème de
l'accès effectif à l'IVG donc d'une
réorganisation de notre système de soins
totalement défaillant en la matière et
de l'instauration de mesure destinées à
remédier notamment au désert médicaux
dès lors le problème de l'effectivité de
l'accès à l'IVG ne sera pas résolu par
un accroissement voir un empilement des
droits et l'inscription de l'accès à
l'IVG au panthéon des valeurs
principales de référence de la France si
symbolique soit-elle ne permettra pas de
régler au quotidien le problème de
toutes ces femmes
au-delà au-delà de ce constat la
rédaction même de ce texte pose de
sérieuses difficultés que nous ne
pouvons pas éluder il y a d'ailleurs il
y a d'ailleurs aucun consensus sur la
manière de constitutionnaliser un droit
à l'IVG les différents textes soumis
tant au Sénat quel Assemblée nationale
avec chacun une rédaction différente
démontre clairement la difficulté de
rédaction de ce texte monsieur peu le
ministre de la justice lui-même n'en
disconviens pas lui qui le 19 octobre
dernier devant les sénateurs et
aujourd'hui encore devant nous déclare
déclarait et déclare une rédaction
inadaptée pourrait en effet conduire à
consacrer un accès sans conditions à
l'IVG je pense par exemple à des IVG
bien au-delà de la limite légale en
vigueur ce qui n'est pas souhaitable
nous en convenons et nous ne pouvons pas
faire abstraction de cette difficulté
effectivement effectivement la
formulation proposée à travers le texte
qui nous est soumis aujourd'hui laisse à
penser que l'IVG serait un droit
inconditionnel et absolue sans que le
législateur ne puisse fixer de board à
ce droit or le législateur doit pouvoir
fixer les conditions comme pour toutes
les libertés publiques et il n'est pas
des raisonnable de penser qu'au détour
d'une QPC pourrait surgir la question
d'une demande d'IVG en dehors de la
limite de délai légal bien au-delà
d'ailleurs de la limite du délai légal
puisque le nul ne pourrait être privé du
droit à l'IVG ce dont Monsieur le
Ministre de la Justice n'a pas dit ce
qu'on venus ce risque est d'autant plus
à craindre que Madame la rapporteur
panneau elle-même a fait état dans le
document d'avancement de ces travaux je
cite d'un droit de créance
au bénéfice de la personne enceinte qui
impose au pouvoir public une obligation
de résultats c'est du point de vue de la
sécurité juridique éminemment dangereux
par ailleurs la mention selon laquelle
la loi garantit à toute personne qui ont
fait la demande un accès libre et
effectif à ses droits est également
hasardeuse car elle ouvre la porte à une
sorte de stipulation pour autrui en
matière d'IVG dès lors la rédaction
problématique de ce texte fait que s'il
était adopté il pourrait se révéler
contraire aux droits qu'il est censé
protéger nous ne pouvons pas apporter
quelques modifications que ce soit à la
constitution sans apprécier les effets
collatéraux inattendus voire pervers des
modifications envisagées cet impératif
de prudence doit tellement calmement
animer les législateurs que nous sommes
de façon à ne pas ouvrir ici ou là la
boîte de Pandore et ne pas voir se créer
des droits et donc des revendications
impossibles à prévoir donc à contenir
mes chers collègues vous ouvrez
aujourd'hui un débat pour modifier la
Constitution comprenez que dans ce débat
des mesures qui nous semblent
primordiales de voir inscrire dans notre
texte
le quotidien de nos compatriotes
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois chers collègues
une fois encore une fois de plus je
répéterai ce que je ne cesse d'affirmer
quand nous abordons la question de
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
jamais je ne me permettrai de juger une
femme qui a recours à l'avortement et je
comprends qu'on puisse y avoir recours
bien entendu mais aujourd'hui cette
précaution oratoire nécessaire tant les
caricatures vont bon train mais pas le
sujet non le sujet qui nous occupe ce
matin ce n'est pas d'être pour ou contre
l'IVG mais pour ou contre son
inscription dans notre Constitution et
pour ma part je ne pense pas je ne crois
pas que l'IVG doivent être inscrite dans
la Constitution et cela pour trois
raisons principales premièrement parce
que c'est inutile j'ai entendu certains
députés expliquer que l'IVG serait
menacé en France
et ce serait pour cette raison qu'il
faudrait la protéger encore un peu plus
menacée par quoi menacé par qui toutes
les modifications législatives depuis la
loi de 1975 sont allés dans le sens de
l'élargissement et de l'assouplissement
des conditions requises pour avorter
allongement des délais par deux fois
suppression du délai de réflexion
suppression du consentement parental
pour les mineurs suppression de la
notion de détresse pour avorter
instauration d'un délit d'entrave
remboursement intégral etc aucun risque
non plus de revirement de la
jurisprudence du Conseil constitutionnel
qui a toujours admis les différentes
réécriture législatives en considérant
qu'il ne lui appartenait pas de se
substituer au législateur bien au
contraire ce serait évidemment la remise
en cause de l'IVG par la loi qui serait
immédiatement censuré par le Conseil
constitutionnel
inutile donc et étonnante votre votre
référence à la décision de la Cour
suprime suprême des États-Unis du 24
juin 2022 pour justifier votre
proposition de loi elle me laisse
pantois quand il est évident qu'on ne
peut en aucun cas importer en France un
débat lié aux spécificités
constitutionnelles des USA qui ne
ressemblent en rien au nôtres je me
permets de vous rappeler au passage que
rendre à chacun des États le pouvoir de
légiférer n'est rien d'autre que la
démocratie même si comme beaucoup
d'entre nous je mesure le risque d'un
retour en arrière dans certains de ces
états et on l'a déjà constaté d'ailleurs
mais quel rapport avec la situation
constitutionnelle en France aucun
dangereux enfin toucher à la
constitution sur une question sociétale
comme l'avortement et a fortiori la
contraception c'est ouvrir la boîte de
Pandore et l'occasion de toutes les
surenchères demain vous voudrez y mettre
le tanasie le droit au changement de
sexe la PMA la GPA bref un catalogue sur
tous les sujets qui à un moment donné
vous paraîtront de voir devenir des
droits et nalinnables et vous ne
manquerez pas d'idées dans la matière de
plus en faisant de l'accès à
l'avortement un droit illimité vous
bouleverser les équilibres trouvés par
la loi veille dont vous ne cessez
pourtant de vous réclamer
fini les délais 16 24 30 semaines chacun
pourra sur enchérir pour ceux qui l'ont
trop vite oublié c'est sur vos bancs que
l'avortement jusqu'à la veille de
l'accouchement pour des tresses
psychosociales a été voté une première
fois en août 2020 avant fort
heureusement de se voir Redé
dangereux aussi pour la clause de
conscience spécifique des médecins et
des personnels médicaux puisque deux
droits fondamentaux s'opposeront alors
le droit à l'IVG et la liberté de
conscience là encore je n'oublie pas
votre acharnement à tenter de la
supprimer contre la vie même de tout le
corps médical en février dernier vous
l'aurez compris je pense que vous prenez
le problème à l'envers
comme le souligne le professeur Israël
Nyon tout le monde peut s'accorder sur
l'idée qu'il vaut mieux prévenir les IVG
plutôt que d'avoir à les réaliser que ce
soit du point de vue éthique
psychologique ou économique or malgré
vos lois à répétition permettant à en
avoir seulement toujours plus facile en
France que disent les chiffres au total
223300ivg ont été enregistrés en 2021
selon une étude de l'adresse un nombre
qui reste stable qui ne diminuent
nullement d'un nez en année ce qui
devrait vous interroger ou vous
inquiétez quelle est l'urgence
aujourd'hui
constitutionnaliser l'IVG ou mettre en
place une véritable politique de
prévention de prévention de l'avortement
notamment chez les jeunes chacun ses
priorités en France nous possédons tous
les instruments juridiques nécessaires
pour protéger les droits de la femme
alors cessez de jouer sur la peur d'une
remise en cause de l'accès à
l'avortement que vous savez impossible
mais
difficile pour vous de résister à ce
petit coup politique n'est-ce pas cela
porte un nom la démagogie une fois de
plus merci madame la députée
monsieur le Président obiez vous
souhaitiez la parole
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la rapporteur
d'abord je salue les orateurs qui ont
appelé les le contexte dans lequel
l'examen de ces propositions de loi et
je disais propositions de loi et je vais
vous expliquer pourquoi s'inscrit c'est
celui du 50e anniversaire du procès de
Bobigny
c'est celui également de la décision de
la Cour suprême des États-Unis qui
indirectement en tout cas en renvoyant
aux États fédérés la possibilité de
décider de leur législation sur
l'avortement aggravement remis en cause
ce droit aux États-Unis d'Amérique
c'est également celui de une remise en
cause
répétée dans plusieurs États de l'Union
européenne vous l'avez dit en Pologne ou
il n'est plus possible d'aborder lorsque
des malformations sont constatées
vous l'avez dit également pour la
Hongrie
où on exige des femmes qui souhaitent
pratiquer un avortement qu'elles
entendent préalablement préalablement à
la pratique d'un avortement
les battements du cœur de l'enfant en
être
ce qui je rejoins la position du
ministre
est une véritable torture
et la litanie de remise en cause du
droit à l'avortement pourrait ne pas
s'arrêter ici quand on connaît les
positions réitérer de Madame mélonie
pardon
je n'arrive même pas à prononcer son nom
qui est pourtant l'allié
qui est pourtant l'allié de certains
députés qui siègent sur ces bancs
sur ce sujet il s'agit pas de faire de
la communication il s'agit de pouvoir
avancer
et pour pouvoir avancer
j'aurais préféré qu'on ait pu examiner
les deux propositions de loi qui ont été
déposées par le groupe Renaissance et
par le groupe de la France insoumise
comme la procédure le permettait avant
la réforme constitutionnelle là encore
de 2008 et donc me vient une question
puisque nous sommes beaucoup interrogés
parfois malheureusement
écharpé sur des rédactions puisque comme
vous l'avez tous constaté c'est au Sénat
que la première tentative a été
présentée et qu'elle a à chopé elle a HP
pourquoi parce que un premier élément
qui ne figure plus d'ailleurs dans les
rédactions
là empêché c'est l'inscription en plus
de la garantie du droit à l'IVG dans le
texte constitutionnel
de la volonté garantir aussi la
contraception sur le principe nous
sommes totalement d'accord
en revanche
dans l'application et par principe de
réalité pour que la réforme
constitutionnelle à son terme nous avons
dû pour cette fois-ci il renoncer
sur le deuxième aspect c'est sur la
rédaction avec deux questions d'abord la
place
de la constitutionnalisation du droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
est-ce que son inscription à l'article
premier permettrait le vote du Sénat sur
cette question il semble que la réponse
soit non
est-ce que son inscription à l'article
66 2 de la Constitution permettrait
l'adoption du droit à l'IVG dans la
Constitution la réponse est certainement
oui et donc il y a parlé un chemin
est-ce que la rédaction qui est proposée
par les rapporteurs et par différents
groupes qui
satisfait la majorité permet aujourd'hui
d'avoir un accord du Sénat je n'en suis
à ce stade pas sûr précisément pour une
raison je vais vous le la présenter
lorsque nous avions adopté l'année
dernière
l'allongement du délai légal de recours
à l'IVG de 12 à 14 semaines nous
l'avions fait
sans l'accord du Sénat précisément parce
que le Sénat souhaite car envoie la loi
une précision selon laquelle le droit
garanti s'exerce dans les conditions
prévues par la loi et bien soit inscrit
ou en tout cas soit garanti pour que le
législateur reste le maître des
conditions dans lesquelles nous
recourions nous encadrons le recours à
l'IVG et c'est précisément cette
question que je pose aujourd'hui c'est
que si sur le principe y compris dans sa
rédaction la plus ambitieuse le groupe
de la majorité et c'est ce que nous
avons vu dans la commission des lois et
la majorité des groupes de cette
hémicycle souhaite une
constitutionnalisation du BG comme elle
souhaite une constitutionnalisation du
droit à la contraception dans son
application nous devons tous faire œuvre
de pragmatisme de principe de réalité je
l'ai dit pour que ce texte chemine et
pour que il permette soit la convocation
d'un congrès à Versailles soit
la présentation d'un référendum au
peuple pour que on ait une délibération
populaire qui ensuite l'inscrivent mais
pour cela il y a une procédure préalable
que vous connaissez qui est celle de
l'article de 89 de la Constitution
laquelle prévoit d'abord avant toute
chose un vote des chambres dans les
mêmes termes et donc vous pouvez compter
je crois sur beaucoup de groupes pour y
parvenir encore faut-il que nous nous
soyons d'accord pour que ce texte fasse
la deuxième barrière qui est celle du
vote sénatorial merci
merci monsieur le Président Houlier à la
demande du gouvernement je suspends la
séance pour une durée de 5 minutes
monsieur breton oui merci madame la
Présidente
expressément la liberté du consentement
de la femme liberté a avorter liberté à
ne pas avorter
il faut que les deux libertés ou cette
même liberté qui s'exerce de deux
manières différentes puissent exister
hors on sait et ça on en connaît autour
de nous qu'il y a parfois des situations
où le conjoint ou le compagnon va mettre
une injonction à l'avortement où ça sera
le milieu familial et où effectivement
la femme va avoir recourir à l'IVG
interruption volontaire de grossesse
mais le mot volontaire ne correspond pas
effectivement à la véritablement à
l'expression de son consentement c'est
l'occasion aussi de saluer le travail
d'association qui sont là aussi pour
accompagner ces femmes qui se retrouvent
mises au rebut dans leur famille ou dans
leur milieu et qui sont là effectivement
pour les accompagner matériellement et
donc je crois que ça serait important
effectivement qu'on est cette
reconnaissance de la liberté du
consentement de la femme à avorter ou à
ne pas avorter
merci monsieur le député l'amendement
414 monsieur Hetzel oui merci beaucoup
madame la Présidente effectivement parmi
les questions qui se posent sont
effectivement celles de la protection
des femmes et on voit bien que dans la
rédaction telle qu'elle était effectuée
aujourd'hui on semble et les débats
n'ont pas porté sur ce point-là et je
pense que ça mérite effectivement une
attention toute particulière il faut
aujourd'hui
faire de la réal politique et regarder
ce qui se passe concrètement il y a
effectivement les conditions dans
lesquelles et bien les femmes peuvent
exercer leur droit d'IVG mais il faut
aussi regarder comment dans certains cas
des pressions peuvent être exercées sur
les femmes et donc à partir de là il
devient essentiel de pouvoir s'assurer
de l'existence effective de la liberté
de consentement et ça
devrait d'ailleurs être aussi une
liberté fondamental et donc la question
qu'on peut vous poser et bien dans votre
rédaction pourquoi ne vous ne le
prévoyez pas et c'est la raison pour
laquelle et bien monsieur Balanant et
bien dans ce cas là accepter accepter
ces sous-amendements parce que ce sont
justement des amendements qui permettent
de donner un certain nombre de garanties
aux femmes et c'est assez paradoxal
lorsque l'on met l'accent sur un certain
nombre de difficultés qui se posent et
bien vous faites comme si elle
n'existait pas quand on voit une réalité
il faut l'avoir dans son ensemble à 360°
et véritablement protéger les femmes on
a l'impression que de vous le souhaitez
pas le faire complètement merci Monsieur
le le député pour la bonne information
de tout le monde je rappelle que si on
veut que les débats se passent dans les
meilleures circonstances il est mieux de
ne pas s'interpeller dans l'hémicycle je
rappelle qu'ici on s'adresse à la
présidente à la rapporteur ou au
ministre le sous-amendement 509
vous avez parfaitement raison Madame la
Présidente effectivement il y a des
pressions qui s'exercent sur les femmes
des pressions de la part des parents à
l'égard des jeunes femmes des pressions
de la part du compagnon du mari mais
aussi des pressions économiques parce
que combien de jeunes femmes se disent
je n'y arriverai pas je ne parviendrai
pas à élever cet enfant et donc il y a
là une vraie difficulté c'est pour ça
mes chers collègues du groupe de la
France insoumise je comprends pas que
vous ayez retiré de l'ordre du jour ce
premier texte qui portait sur le SMIC
vous aviez mis dans la rue un certain
nombre de gens le 16 octobre votre
priorité semble-t-il c'était votre
priorité semble-t-il c'était le pouvoir
d'achat aujourd'hui nous assistons à la
misère vous avez privilégié le sociétal
sur le social faites attention les
socialistes ont fait pareil hier
ce sont effondré et attention ces gens
que vous avez mis dans la rue ils sont
pas venus pour la Corrida ils sont pas
venus pour la constitutionnalisation de
l'avortement ils sont venus pour le
pouvoir d'achat et attention mes chers
collègues Google Rennes parce que moi je
suis très juste avec tout le monde si
vous si vous allez également vers le
sociétal vous aurez les mêmes épreuves
que ceux qui les socialistes hier le
groupe et les filles aujourd'hui ont été
vers le sociétal donc voilà j'aurais
alerté tout le monde dans un esprit
d'équité
merci monsieur le député l'amendement
numéro 161
madame rixin le 161 il est défendu
oui peut-être également rappeler en tout
cas que dans le cas des auditions
préparatoires auxquelles j'ai pu
participer il a été rappelé la nécessité
d'inscrire à l'article premier
de notre Constitution
là le droit à l'avortement je crois que
c'est important de rappeler que notre
pacte social aujourd'hui notre
Constitution date peut-être en tout cas
a été écrite par des hommes
pour des hommes et que finalement
peut-être notre Constitution aujourd'hui
a besoin d'intégrer également les droits
des femmes et donc je crois absolument
essentiel que notre article premier
intègre ces ces dispositions dire
également que finalement à travers
l'avortement et l'inscription de
l'avortement dans notre Constitution ce
que nous voulons inscrire ce sont plus
généralement les droits sexuels et
reproductifs nous l'avons vu aux
États-Unis nous le voyons en Europe à la
fois Hong en Pologne ce qui est touché à
chaque fois parler
conservateurs c'est et bien la
possibilité pour les femmes de disposer
de leur corps que ce soit en rongeant le
droit à l'avortement ou en les privant
du droit à la contraception c'est la
raison pour laquelle je suis absolument
partisane à la fois d'inscrire le droit
à l'IVG mais également le droit à la
contraception on voit à quel point les
conservateurs lorsqu'ils touchent le
droit à l'IVG touche également le droit
à la contraception
merci madame la députée madame la
rapporteur sur tous ces amendements et
sous amendements merci madame la
Présidente d'abord pour répondre aux
nombreuses questions qui ont été posées
par les LR je comprends que cette
discussion ait lieu en commission la
semaine précédente sur une formulation
négative nul ne peut être privé je
comprends que les questions se posent
mais quand on écrit noir sur blanc ce
que nous proposons la loi garantie je ne
vois pas où vous trouvez des choses qui
pourraient donner un droit à un
conditionnel sur la question de l'IVG
donc je pense que ce n'est pas la peine
de reprendre dessus la loi garantie y
compris revient à ce que vous disiez sur
la question de la loi deuxième chose et
pour être très brève puisque j'aimerais
qu'on arrive à le voter avant 13h
c'était possible je suis favorable de
131 276 monsieur baladant avec le sous
amendement favorable aussi au 588 655
j'étais favorable à celui de Madame
rixin notamment puisque j'étais heureuse
propose de voir que la contraception est
figurait et je crois que c'était
important mais vu l'accord que nous
sommes en train de trouver et dans un
esprit de consensus avec une grande
partie de cette émission que je vous
propose de le retirer
merci Madame la rapporteur monsieur le
garde des sceaux
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames
Messieurs les Députés j'ai commencé si
vous le voulez bien par l'amendement de
Monsieur
Erwan Balanant le Gouvernement émet un
avis de sagesse je pense que le
pragmatisme et le réalisme sont au
rendez-vous de cet amendement nous
savons ce qui est susceptible d'aboutir
ce qui ne l'est pas et vous l'avez de
mon point de vue parfaitement exprimée
de la même façon s'agissant madame la
présidente des sous amendements des
députés batistel et Vigier qui porte les
numéros 588 et
655 c'est également un avis de sagesse
car de notre point de vue la position
doit encore être affinée de la même
façon l'amendement de madame panot qui
porte le numéro 276 qui est ident qu'en
réalité à celui de Monsieur Balanant
évidemment c'est la même position c'est
une position de sagesse il s'agissant de
l'amendement déposé par Madame
Marie-Pierre rexin j'entends évidemment
ce que vous dites mais
l'idée c'est pas d'aller se fracasser
contre un écueil
d'ores et déjà dressé et dont nous
savons qu'il sera difficilement
contournable et je vous suggère un
retrait à défaut naturellement je me
verrai dans l'obligation de vous dire
que le Gouvernement est défavorable
enfin l'amendement déposé par madame la
Présidente Le Pen
toujours un grand privilège pour moi
d'échanger avec madame la Présidente Le
Pen qui n'a jamais souhaité directement
échanger avec moi mais
par le truchement de Monsieur garrot qui
devait selon ses espérances de venir le
prochain garde des sceaux
totalement hors sujet mais
je peux vous dire un certain nombre de
choses et au fond c'est un hommage que
je rends la présidente Le Pen en lui
disant que c'est un grand privilège pour
moi et un grand honneur que d'échanger
avec elle alors madame la Présidente Le
Pen vous souhaitez en réalité que le
code de la santé publique
entre dans le préambule de la
Constitution qui me soit permis de vous
dire que c'est un ovni c'est un objet
juridique non identifié pourquoi parce
qu'une fois que vous avez intégré le
code de la santé publique ben rien rien
madame la Présidente
rien madame rien madame ne protège ses
dispositions or le but pardonnez-moi le
but c'est de protéger le droit à
l'avortement c'est pas autre chose donc
donc c'est peut-être pas votre but je
l'entends bien mais une fois que vous
avez retenu ce qui vous intéresse dans
le Code de la Santé pardon de vous dire
que ces modifiable le législateur pourra
modifier le texte quand il l'entendra
enfin je note et là c'est peut-être un
peu plus grave qu'en juin sur cette
question vous dites je vous cite madame
la Présidente pourquoi pas la semaine
dernière dans le Journal du Dimanche
vous dites c'est non et puis hier et
plusieurs en pensant prendre tout le
monde par surprise vous dites c'est
finalement oui c'est Madame
c'est Madame trois temps le temps de la
valse peut-être celle de Vienne
monsieur le garde des sceaux madame Blin
pour un rappel au règlement
[Applaudissements]
mais
madame Blin vous avez la parole la
présidente sur la base de l'article 100
de notre règlement madame le rapporteur
vous évoquez la question de la
commission mais ayez l'honnêteté de dire
que ce dispositif le dispositif écrit
par Monsieur Balanant et que l'on va
voter que vous allez faire voter
maintenant n'a pas été examiné par la
commission cet accord que vous avez
trouvé hier soir et ce matin a fait
l'objet d'un dépôt d'amendement en même
terme par Monsieur Balanant et vous-même
parce que vous avez trouvé un accord
avec les macronistes pour faire voter un
nouveau dispositif que nous n'avons pas
pu examiner en commission donc ne dites
pas que les sous amendements ne sont pas
pu faire le travail parlementaire
monsieur Balanant pour un rappel au
Règlement sur le sur le fondement de la
mise en cause personnelle madame madame
Blin vous êtes en train de mentir tout
simplement je vous le dis je vous le dis
avec délicatesse laissez-moi finir je
vous ai pas interpellé je vous ai laissé
pour finir c'est amendement que nous
vous proposons on l'a on l'a examiné en
commission
commission comment dire sur le texte de
Madame panot avec une différence et nous
avons supprimé cette différence donc il
y a pas de sujet il y a pas de secret et
c'est amendement il a été déposé dans
les délais tout simplement dans les
délais évidemment dans les mêmes thèmes
parce que depuis à peu près deux heures
je suis en train de vous dire que c'est
un travail collectif et commun auquel
vous avez même été invités
en commission ce matin
Madame Le Pen vous souhaitiez
d'atteindre est-ce que vous m'aviez
demandé une suspension de séance est-ce
qu'elle est toujours
j'aurais bien solliciter une suspension
de séance de 2 minutes si je suis sûr
que nous votons à l'issue de cette
suspension de séance avant de suspendre
pour le déjeuner sinon je renonce à ma
suspension de séance et j'explique
ce que je souhaite faire de mon
amendement
j'explique ce que je voulais faire parce
que tout le monde soit bien soit bien au
courant on est en niche je suis obligé
de suspendre à 13h voilà alors par
conséquent compte tenu de la proposition
qui a été faite par Monsieur balade en
qui correspond tout à fait d'ailleurs à
mes engagements présidentiels ça va
rassurer Monsieur Le Fur parce que
j'étais dans le domaine sociétal pour un
moratoire un moratoire sur la loi
existante vous voyez on est sur le
moratoire sur la loi existante il
m'apparaît que avec le sous amendement
655 et l'amendement 231 ça répond à
l'inquiétude sur l'inconditionnalité des
délais qui était le plus gros reproche
que nous avions à faire sur le texte de
la France insoumise ça répond au respect
de la clause de conscience puisque ça
renvoie en réalité à la loi comme source
essentielle du droit et donc monsieur le
ministre de la Justice ça revient
exactement à ce que je proposais avec
mon propre abonnement mais j'ai bien
compris quand c'est moi qui propose
c'est pas bon quand c'est les autres et
quand ce sont particulièrement vos amis
c'est bon
j'ai encore une fois rappelé que je
considère que cette
constitutionnalisation n'était pas utile
et ne correspondait pas à l'urgence qui
est celle de nos compatriotes
aujourd'hui n'en demeure pas moins que
la rédaction de Monsieur Balanant est
bien meilleure que celle de la France
insoumise et donc je retire mon
proprement
merci madame la Présidente Le Pen
nous allons maintenant procéder au
scrutin je mets donc au vol amendement
231 et identique je vous prie de bien
vouloir regagner vos places
le scrutin est ouvert
[Musique]
le scrutin est clos
voici le résultat du scrutin votant 253
exprimés 238 majorités 120 pour 226
contre 12 l'Assemblée nationale a adopté
nous venons à des amendements sur le
titre
amendement numéro 10 de Madame Ménard
qui pourrait nous présenter le 11 et le
avec un mineur si vous le voulez bien
merci madame la Présidente oui bien sûr
pour vous être agréable je défendrai les
trois en même temps je vous rassure ce
sont trois amendements qui portent sur
le sujet de l'introduction de l'IVG dans
la Constitution
et puis j'en profite quand même pour
souligner que c'est assez cocasse de
s'entendre faire un procès en
obstruction en permanence de la part
d'un groupe qui je le rappelle a déposé
19000 amendements sur la proposition le
projet de loi sur les retraites
et qui et qui équipe à plus tard que la
semaine dernière nous a fait passer des
heures sur le montant de l'aide des
amendes forfaitaire délictuels en
proposant de faire passer le montant de
800 euros à 30 centimes puis 55 centimes
puis un euro puis deux euros donc
l'arroseur est arrosé
ce sont trois amendements madame la
Présidente sur le titre parce que vous
le savez une constitution est un
ensemble de textes juridiques qui
définit les institutions de l'État et
organisent leur relation cette
constitution peut aussi rappeler des
principes et des droits fondamentaux et
elle constitue la règle la plus élevée
de l'ordre juridique d'un point de vue
plus philosophique la Constitution est
un acte fondateur par lequel une société
se constitue une identité se rassemblent
et se reconnaît alors laissez croire
comme le fait la France insoumise que
les droits sexuels et reproductifs ou
l'IVG serait en danger en France est une
imposture au Sénat la sénatrice Laurence
Rossignol s'est emporté au moment de la
discussion de la position de loi de la
sénatrice mais la nivogel et elle dit et
elle a dit je la cite oui l'IVG
peut-être menacé en France oui nous
devons inscrire le droit à l'avortement
dans la Constitution je me battrai
contre tous les intégrer c'est les
conservateurs qui veulent nous renvoyer
à l'avortement clandestin sa maman je
vois pas très bien de qu'elle voulait
parler mais elle s'est aussi risquée à
comparer ceux qui oblige à dissimuler le
corps des femmes vous êtes tellement
prévisible ce qui oblige à dissimuler le
corps des femmes et ceux qui leur
interdisent de choisir quand et avec qui
elles veulent être mère alors face à
temps de démagogie on a plutôt
l'impression qu'il ne s'agit pas de
protéger un droit de la femme en danger
mais plutôt d'imposer simplement
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
comme principe constituant de la société
française et c'est l'objet de mes trois
amendements sur le titre je vous
remercie madame la Présidente je vous
remercie madame Ménard madame la
rapporteur sur les trois favorables
défavorable sur les trois monsieur
des Philippot
merci madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur c'est une des dernières
occasions pour nous d'aller au bout de
ce débat et de voter de manière éclairée
je vais vous faire une proposition des
plus honnête
je suis prêt à voter le texte
si vous vous engagez à lutter avec moi
pour garantir la clause de conscience
des médecins
et aussi à conserver le délai de recours
à l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
à 14 semaines tel qu'il est prévu dans
le droit aujourd'hui et à défendre ces
choses là avec moi de manière
inconditionnelle et alors nous serons
tous les deux très honnêtes et je
pourrais vous accompagner candide vous
c'est l'occasion peut-être la dernière
de répondre à mes questions
je vous remercie je vous en prie
1 2 merci madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur chers collègues madame Ménard
néo député nous partageons pas vos idées
j'ai malgré tout de l'intérêt pour votre
travail constant sur de très nombreux
textes je salue d'ailleurs votre
attention au Biterrois ville de
naissance de Pierre Paul Riquet mais je
dois avouer être concerné par vos
propositions et ses amendements sur le
sujet si important que l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse mi bout à bout
vos amendements laissent apparaître de
grandes lacunes tous n'ont pas pu être
examinés c'est heureux car si vous
remettiez en cause dans la digne Liné
réactionnaire la PMA le droit à mourir
dans la dignité et surtout le droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
madame Ménard laissez-moi vous rappeler
quelques vérités vous dites que vous
voulons faire de l'avortement un acte
anodin c'est faux c'est parce que cet
acte n'est jamais anodin qui est
l'expression d'une décision lourde de
sens pour une femme qui ne pratique
librement et en pleine conscience nous
voulons le protéger vous vous rappelez
plusieurs fois que Simon Vevey disait
que la porte l'avortement est un drame
vous avez raison
mais est-ce que mais il est encore plus
c'est que toutes les 9 minutes une femme
meurt parce qu'elle est contrainte
avortée clandestinement vous
sous-entendez que nous mettons vous
souvent entendez que nous mettons en
affirmant que nous que nous mentons en
affirmant que l'IVG est en danger mais
regardez autour de vous il est aux
États-Unis mais aussi sur le sol
européen comme en Pologne ou en Hongrie
ou à nouveau des femmes meurent de ne
pas voir pu avorter en France le
rassemblement national souhaitait le
dérembourser et Madame Le Pen parler
d'avortement de confort encore plus
récemment une députée de ce parti est
allée jusqu'à parler de génocide les
temps changent et Madame Le Pen comme
souvent aussi
l'avortement est comme tous les jours
d'une petite touche comme la vôtre est
en d'autres mises en cause alors oui le
droit l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse est en danger oui il doit être
protégé et c'est pour cela que nous
voulons l'inscrire dans la Constitution
je vous remercie
nous allons passer au vote sur ces
amendements le numéro 10 avec avis
défavorable de la commission et
défavorable du gouvernement qui pour
qui contre l'amendement est rejeté le 11
double avis défavorable commission
gouvernement qui est pour qui contre des
rejeté et le numéro 12 même avis même
vote
à maman 232 sur lequel il n'y a plus
scrutin public monsieur vivier
oui merci Monsieur le Ministre
simplement en cohérence avec toutes les
discussions que nous avons eu depuis le
début de la matinée sur ce texte
important sur le droit à l'avortement le
garantir et le mettre dans le droit
constitutionnel simplement de précision
qui arrive le mot contraception je
voudrais simplement dire à tous les
collègues attentifs qu'ils sont que dans
le fameux pile FSS 2023 que beaucoup
n'ont pas voté la pilule du lendemain
l'interrupteur justement cette
possibilité donnée aux femmes en urgence
d'avoir un traitement a été validé par
l'Assemblée le gouvernement qu'on le
sache bien c'est important
je vous remercie madame la rapporteur
merci à madame la Présidente avis
favorable par cohérence au consensus que
nous avons trouvé sur les différents
bancs de l'hémicycle même si je pense
que dans une étape prochaine il faudra
inscrire et le droit à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse et le droit à la
contraception parce que ce sont des
droits qui sont corollaires et qui sont
liés et notamment parce que je le redis
en Pologne et la délégation des droits
des femmes de manière trans partisane la
redit lorsqu'on Pologne on attaque le
droit et on entrave le droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
on interdit aussi la pilule du lendemain
sans ordonnance dernière chose Monsieur
de Philippot je le redis je vais le
redire pour la énième et dernière fois
quand vous écrivez la loi garantit
l'effectivité les galaxies aux droits à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
ce que nous demandons avec la
constitutionnalisation de ce droit c'est
le droit à l'IVG tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui tel qu'il est aujourd'hui
même si je suis partisane de la
suppression de la double clause de
conscience
je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre
merci merci madame la Présidente le
Gouvernement est favorable à
l'amendement déposé par monsieur le
député Philippe Vigier
uyons s'il vous plaît
madame la Présidente mon groupe aurait
besoin d'une de la deuxième suspension
de séance s'il vous plaît
la séance est suspendue pour une durée
de 3 minutes chers collègues je vous
annonce que sur le vote de l'ensemble de
la proposition de loi constitutionnelles
je suis saisie par le groupe la France
insoumise par le groupe démocrate modem
et indépendant et par le groupe
socialiste et à parenté d'une demande de
scrutin public le scrutin est annoncé
dans l'enceinte de l'Assemblée nationale
[Musique]
je vais mettre au voile amendement
numéro 232 qui avait obtenu un avis
favorable de la commission et favorable
du gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre la maman est adoptée
nous en venons aux explications de vote
sur le texte
la parole est à Monsieur Patrick Hetzel
pour le groupe les républicains pour une
durée de 5 minutes
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
avant tout je voudrais rappeler ici que
notre groupe au début de la discussion
de ce texte insister sur le fait que de
manière très claire nous étions attachés
à la loi veille du 17 janvier 1975 et
notamment à ses grands principes
c'est-à-dire y compris avec un certain
nombre d'évolutions qui ont pu avoir
lieu dès lors qu'elles ne remettent pas
en cause les grands principes et nous
proposions de constitutionnaliser ces
principes fondamentaux tant évidemment
sur le droit de la femme a demandé
l'interruption volontaire de grossesses
que de respecter évidemment le
commencement de la vie en proposant
d'inscrire dans la Constitution que nul
ne peut être privé du droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
en réalité on a assisté au cours des
débats à une évolution très claire qui
en réalité montre que les équilibres
fondamentaux qui sont vraiment les
principes de la loi Veil ne sont plus
respectés et à partir de là nous avions
nous considérer que il fallait en tout
cas faire en sorte qu'il y ait des
garanties que c'est garanti chouette
effectuer nous avons posé un certain
nombre de questions à Monsieur le garder
show concernant ces garanties et là nous
n'avons pas eu de réponse et c'est là
aussi nous avons été extrêmement surpris
collectivement de voir que on a expédié
en quelque sorte notre amendement qui
était un amendement qui permettait là
aussi de poser un certain nombre de
choses et c'est la raison pour laquelle
et bien notre groupe a poursuivi je
dirais les débats en posant des
questions qui sont restées hélas sans
réponse je voudrais terminer en disant
que très clairement sur les sujets
sociétaux notre groupe a toujours
considéré qu'il y avait liberté de vote
mais encore une fois ce que l'on peut
déplorer c'est que le gouvernement là
dessus a été extrêmement manichéen et
que encore une fois Monsieur le garder
show vous avez utilisé un certain nombre
d'arguments en disant il faut
constitutionnaliser et lorsque l'on
évoque un certain nombre de garanties
nécessaires pour maintenir l'équilibre
qui était vraiment la base même de la
loiveil et bien vous utilisez les mêmes
arguments pour dire le contraire et ça
ça interroge les interrogations
aujourd'hui sont quand même extrêmement
nombreuses et voir aujourd'hui cette
alliance entre la majorité
présidentielle le gouvernement et
évidemment la nu-pêche interroge une
fois de plus d'autant plus que il y a
des bruits qui circulent comme quoi
madame berger allait retirer le texte de
renaissance montrant une nouvelle fois
que là aussi il y a des choses qui en
réalité ne sont pas transparentes et qui
en réalité ne permettent pas un débat
éclairé
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Erwan Balanant pour le groupe
modem démocrate et indépendant
voilà nous avons eu ce matin et en ce
début d'après-midi un débat riche et un
débat je pense qui fait honneur au
travail parlementaire
on avait la chance d'avoir deux
propositions de loi sur le même sujet
proposition de loi de Madame panot et
proposition de loi de Madame berger
quelque part ça nous a donné un temps de
réflexion de travail double temps en
commission et et un travail qui a pu
être fait avec une recherche de
consensus nous nous y sommes arrivés
l'amendement qui a été voté tout à
l'heure qui a un amendement
transpartisan a été voté dans tous les
groupes à la majorité sauf un les
républicains
dans l'ensemble des groupes
majoritairement tout le monde a voté ce
dispositif donc nous montrons par ce
vote notre capacité à travailler
ensemble quand les sujets réclament le
dépassement des clivages et je pense
vraiment que par ce vote par ce travail
nous honorons le travail nous en aurons
le skel au Parlement et nous donnons un
message aussi aux Français c'est-à-dire
que parfois au-delà de nos différences
au-delà de nos contradictions politiques
nous sommes en capacité d'aller dans le
sens
de la réponse la plus proche aux
préoccupations des Françaises et en
l'occurrence sur ce sujet aux
préoccupations des Françaises
notre texte est équilibré je le redis
par la définition de l'effectivité de
l'égal accès nous nous gravons dans le
marbre la possibilité pour les femmes de
bénéficier de pouvoir
avoir ce droit ce droit à l'IVG et le
terme
IVG il est inscrit dans le marbre aussi
et c'est une référence forte une
référence historique à la loi veille la
loi veille c'était justement ça à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
et je le redis au républicains qui ont
un peu tremblé aujourd'hui comme ils
avaient majoritairement tremblé
d'ailleurs en 75
le le
ce qui est écrit c'est interruption
volontaire de grossesse donc on laisse
évidemment
aux femmes la capacité la liberté de
choisir et c'est aussi ça que nous
apportons comme message après avoir
apporté un message aux Français par
cette capacité à travailler ensemble
nous apportons aussi un message au reste
du monde et cette loi est aussi une
réponse à la loi à la et aussi une
réponse à la décision de la Cour suprême
américaine dans notre pays nous
affirmons haut et fort que les droits
acquis par les femmes que les droits
acquis par les femmes et par les hommes
n'auront pas de régression et nous
continuerons le combat pour qu'elle
continue à avancer je remercie tous les
parlementaires qui ont travaillé sur ce
sujet aujourd'hui et les jours derniers
évidemment madame berger madame panot
madame rixin madame beltistel je vais en
oublier je madame bateau madame
je vais en oublier mais elle se
reconnaîtront merci à elle madame Elsa
fossillon
voilà est-ce que excusez moi
excusez-moi mes chers amis le moment est
important laissez-moi aller jusqu'au
bout j'avais prévu de faire moins tout
mais si vous voulez je peux aller
jusqu'au 5 minutes donc pour conclure
nous en aurons le travail parlementaire
par ce vote et continuons le combat
parce qu'il n'est pas fini il faudra
acquérir il faudra aller chercher la le
vote des sénateurs et après j'espère que
le gouvernement pourra reprendre ça à
son compte pour un projet de loi et je
remercie évidemment monsieur le garde
des sceaux pour son avis de sagesse mais
une sagesse bien éclairée sur les débats
d'aujourd'hui
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Marie-Noël
Baptiste elle pour le groupe socialiste
et à part en cours
oui merci madame la Présidente je
voulais aussi rappeler là notre plaine
satisfaction du groupe socialiste pour
l'adoption qui va je l'espère arriver
dans quelques minutes dans cette
émission c'est un grand jour pour le
droit des femmes je crois que nous avons
su collectivement travailler à cette
adoption et je voulais ici remercier
l'ensemble des parlementaires de tous
les groupes politiques parce que je sais
que dans chacun des groupes il y a eu
des voix qui vont contribuer à cette
adoption je voulais aussi remercier les
les rapporteurs de plusieurs textes dont
évidemment Mathilde panneaux qui
rapporte aujourd'hui celui-ci qui a
permis un travail collectif avec aussi
de nombreux groupes de l'Assemblée pour
revenir sur l'écriture de ce texte je le
dirai moi-même c'était pas mon écriture
privée léger au départ mais en tout cas
c'est aussi le travail du Parlement que
d'être dans leur recherche d'une voix
consensuelle c'est ce que nous avons
fait remercier le garde des sceaux et
son écoute aujourd'hui pour pour cet
adoption remercier bien évidemment
Aurore berger qui a travaillé aussi sur
un texte qui nous a été proposé en
commission qui rejoint sur l'essentiel
cette proposition d'aujourd'hui en tout
cas je crois que avec nous tous ici
rassemblé nous allons pouvoir contribuer
à ce grand pas aujourd'hui vers
l'inscription de ce droit dans la
Constitution je crois que c'est vraiment
un jour extrêmement important pour le
droit des femmes alors maintenant
peut-être monsieur le garde des sceau je
me tourne vers vous pour vous dire que
nous comptons sur vous pour que vous
puissiez nous proposer un projet de loi
le plus rapidement possible pour que ce
soit vraiment une inscription définitive
dans la Constitution merci à et tous
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Anne-Cécile
violent pour le groupe horizon et à
parenté
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame le rapporteur chers
collègue
la rédaction que nous avons adopté à
recueillie effectivement des voies
venues de tous les groupes politiques de
cette assemblée et c'est une victoire
c'est d'abord et avant tout une victoire
pour toutes les femmes de France c'est
aussi une victoire légistique la
rédaction que nous venons d'adopter
préserve notre droit actuel et nous
oblige
elle nous oblige à nous assurer que ce
droit soit encore davantage effectif
qu'il soit accessible par toutes et sur
tout le territoire
c'est aussi une victoire humaniste parce
qu'elle est le fruit d'un travail
transpartisant qu'il faut souligner
notamment avec madame le rapporteur et
Monsieur Avanne Balan
nous nous réjouissons donc que la
rédaction sur laquelle nous nous
apprêtons à nous prononcer correspondant
tout point à la rédaction proposée par
notre amendement commun
le travail transpartisan qui s'est
engagé dès la commission des lois sur
les propositions de loi déposées tant
par Madame berger que par madame panot
est une preuve que nous sommes capables
de travailler tous ensemble au-delà des
clivages politiques lorsqu'il s'agit de
sujets aussi essentiels que la
constitutionnalisation du droit à l'IVG
au fantasme d'accord sociétaux entre
groupes évoqué ce matin dont je n'ai pas
tout à fait compris le concept je veux
opposer la sagesse politique des députés
qui ont su dépasser leur clivage pour
défendre ce droit fondamental bien que
ne partageons pas la même vision de la
société
le groupe horizon et à parenté votre a
cette proposition de loi
constitutionnelle telle qu'elle a été
amendée par notre assemblée je vous
remercie
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Jérémy urdanov pour le groupe
écologiste merci madame la Présidente
suis affligé vraiment affligé par
l'attitude et le niveau des débats sur
une partie de nos bancs
nos concitoyens jugeront
nous écologistes aurions bien sûr
préféré une inscription du dispositif
dans l'article premier de la
Constitution et continuer aussi la
contraception ceci étant l'adoption
d'une rédaction commune est une
excellente nouvelle nous en félicitons
réellement
en dépit de la tonalité des débats je le
disais c'est un grand jour il faut
mesurer que c'est un grand jour je
souhaite à ce texte une adoption très
large dans cette assemblée et le même
succès demain au Sénat l'inscription de
l'IVG dans la Constitution est à portée
de main je vous remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame elsafossillon
pour le groupe de la Gauche démocrate et
républicaine merci madame la Présidente
je veux dire au nom du groupe GDR nups
notre émotion et notre fierté notre
conviction juste avant de voter ce texte
qui va permettre la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG on sait
que il y a encore du chemin pour que ce
soit réellement effectif nous sommes
déterminés à mener ce combat pour que ce
texte aille jusqu'au bout et nous le
voyons aussi comme un message un message
de soutien un message comme un plaidoyer
pour l'universalisme de ce droit et je
crois que notre détermination est bien
elle est aussi au service de toutes ces
femmes qui au travers du monde se
battent encore pour un droit à l'IVG je
pense au texane je pense au hongroise je
pense au malgache aux Italiens et c'est
aussi à elle qu'on dédie ce combat
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Benjamin sintri
pour le groupe liberté indépendant
outre-mer et territoire
merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur ministre
madame la rapporteur je m'exprime en mon
nom personnel et au nom de l'immense
majorité du groupe liotte pour redonner
d'abord un point de méthode ce sera un
vrai pour LFI aujourd'hui ce sera vrai
pour les autres niches parlementaires le
groupe se refuse à participer à une
logique d'obstruction nous avons un jour
par groupe et nous le resterons dans
cette situation pour permettre à chacun
de défendre ces options et de permettre
aussi à la représentation nationale de
pouvoir se positionner nous nous sommes
évidemment très attachés aux droits des
femmes et alors capacité à décider de
leur vie de disposer de leur corps et
évidemment cette discussion nous
l'attendions avec intérêt étant
conscient que au-delà de la niche NFI la
majorité présidentielle en tout cas le
groupe Renaissance avait prévu de
déposer le texte dans des conditions à
peu près similaires nous l'aurions très
largement très majoritairement voté et
donc nous le ferons aujourd'hui avec
force conscient que les Français en joie
dernier ont souhaité de fait une
représentation proportionnelle de
l'Assemblée nationale et qui nous
appartient donc en sagesse de créer les
conditions quand cela est possible de
convergence nous nous réjouissons
aujourd'hui que l'ensemble des bancs de
l'Assemblée en tout cas de seuls et ceux
qui ont travaillé à la rédaction de ce
texte et plus particulièrement de
l'amendement qui a permis la convergence
soit en situation d'être largement
majoritaire enfin je veux dire à
certains qui ont usé de faune que nous
vous voyons il aura fallu il aura fallu
deux suspensions de séances au
rassemblement national pour savoir quoi
faire vous avez des colonnes vertébrales
de plastique comme la chef a changé vous
allez changer nous le regrettons mais
nous savons d'où vous venez faisons en
sorte de donner de la force à ce texte
pour qu'au Sénat enfin il trouve éco et
résonance merci à vous
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Aurore berger
pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois madame la rapporteur
on a tous des héritages des héritages
personnels qui guident nos engagements
et qui doivent normalement guider les
raisons qui font que nous avons eu envie
de devenir parlementaire de nous exposer
et de solliciter le suffrage des
Français la question du combat des
droits des femmes de leur liberté de
leur émancipation a toujours été au
coeur des combats que j'ai mené avant de
revenir dans cette émission puisque je
n'avais pas tout avait prévu d'être là
cet après-midi j'ai appelé une seule
personne qui se trouve être ma maman et
si je vous parle d'elle c'est parce
qu'elle m'a donné l'autorisation de le
faire ma mère a eu recours à
l'avortement à un moment où c'était
illégal dans notre pays
elle y a eu recours comme peut-être un
certain nombre de nos maires de nos
grand-mères elle y a eu recours dans un
moment où elle risquait la prison et
elle risquait sa vie où elle a d'abord
fait appel à un médecin
vraisemblablement assez connu à l'époque
pour cela mais l'opération c'est pas
très bien passée
et comme pour de trop nombreuses femmes
elle a dû ensuite aller à l'hôpital à
l'hôpital où elle pensait trouver un
refuge un refuge bienveillant un refuge
accueillant elle a été reçue sous une
forme d'inquisition parce qu'on avait
bien compris évidemment l'acte qu'elle
avait tenté de réaliser à ce moment là
et alors alors qu'elle était dans les
mains de médecins et bien ce qui s'est
passé à ce moment là c'est qu'elle a en
effet pu mettre un terme à sa grossesse
mais qu'elle a subi un curetage sans
anesthésie voilà ce qui se passait voilà
ce que les femmes subissaient voilà ce
que nos maires ont pu subir voilà ce que
nos grands-mères ont pu subir la
question de l'accès à l'IVG la question
de sa protection c'est pas un caprice
c'est pas un gain politique c'est pas
une question de groupe politique les
Français on a cessé de le dire ici ont
d'ailleurs fait en sorte que nous ayons
une nouvelle assemblée et que nous
arrivions à démontrer que nous pouvions
travailler différemment c'est sur la
question des droits des femmes nous ne
sommes pas capables de le faire alors
nous serons capables de le faire sur
aucun texte et je crois que c'est la
démarche qui est la nôtre aujourd'hui
alors je le dis très clairement et très
nettement le texte que nous nous
apprêtons à voter et je l'espère avec la
plus large majorité possible aujourd'hui
ce texte là devient le texte de notre
assemblée devient le texte qui doit
toutes et tous nous réunir devient le
texte qui doit pouvoir aboutir parce que
nous ne devons pas finir notre mandat de
parlementaire sans que notre
Constitution ait été modifiée sans que
l'IVG ait été intégré à notre
Constitution c'est ça l'engagement que
nous devons prendre c'est ça
l'engagement que nous prenons
aujourd'hui en votant ce texte
en votant ce texte qui sera le texte
unique sur ce sujet alors je le dis de
manière claire
au nom de toutes les femmes au nom de
toutes nos mères qui se sont battus au
nom de toutes nos filles qui n'ont plus
jamais à devoir se battre je l'espère
oui je suis ici pour cela pour voter ce
texte et j'espère qu'il sera voté de
manière très large aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Madame Pascal bord pour
le groupe rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente
avait pour objet de créer un droit
inconditionnel à l'IVG et de faire en
sorte que certaines femmes puissent
avorter à 8 ou 9 mois ce qui est
inadmissible et totalement
inenvisageable
ce texte ce texte
marque pour moi une défaite cuisante de
la gauche de cette gauche radicale et
radicalisée qui n'a pour boussole que la
fin de notre monde la fin du monde tel
que nous le connaissons
c'est grâce effectivement un travail
transpartisan c'est grâce à l'amendement
de Marine Le Pen que la majorité que la
majorité a réécrit rapidement très
rapidement son texte texte qui sera
soumis dans quelques instants au vote
c'est devant devant effectivement cette
réécriture
cette réécriture qui qui est un moindre
mal Marine Le Pen a effectivement retiré
son amendement
le texte le texte voté
ne change rien en termes de droit
puisqu'il renvoie à la loi mais ça n'est
pas je vous le rappelle une protection
absolue c'est la raison pour laquelle il
nous faudra rester de tout temps
extrêmement vigilant ce texte je vous le
disais est un moindre mal je souhaite en
terminer en indiquant à nos concitoyens
en indiquant aux Français qu'ils peuvent
comme ils l'ont toujours fécompté sur
nous pour défendre leurs droits tout
leur droit et notamment le pouvoir
d'achat puisque elle est fille a eu
l'indécence
de supprimer de la liste des textes à
examiner le texte sur le SMIC alors
alors que nos concitoyens
alors que nos concitoyens ont d'autres
soucis aujourd'hui que le texte sur
l'IVG qui est certes un texte important
mais moins important que le pouvoir
d'achat pour la totalité de nos
concitoyens
qui pourront toujours tenter sur nous
je vous remercie
l'ensemble des groupes s'est en exprimé
je veux mettre au voie le texte de la
proposition de loi constitutionnelle
merci de bien vouloir regagner vos
places
[Musique]
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
résultat du scrutin votant 387 exprimé
369 majorités 185 pour 337 contre 32
l'Assemblée nationale a adopté la
proposition de loi constitutionnelle
chers collègues
je vais donner
je vais donner la parole pour quelques
mots successivement madame la rapporteur
monsieur le président de commission et
enfin Monsieur le Ministre collègue je
suis très très émue à la fois de ce vote
et de ce signaler historique
que l'Assemblée nationale sonore a
envoyé à toutes les femmes de notre pays
mais aussi à l'ensemble des femmes du
monde
je suis très ému de voir que malgré
l'obstruction qui n'en a pas terminé
jusqu'à son terme nous avons su dégager
collectivement un consensus avec la
conscience du temps long persuadé que
nous faisons acte de progrès pas
seulement pour nous-mêmes mais aussi
pour les générations à venir
aujourd'hui collègue l'Assemblée
nationale par le monde aujourd'hui
collègues notre pays par le monde
la France en introduisant le droit à
l'avortement dans la Constitution serait
la nation pionnière en matière des
droits des femmes il est temps que notre
pays s'affirme comme à l'avant-garde de
la protection des droits sexuels et
reproductifs monsieur le ministre
maintenant la balle est dans le camp du
gouvernement nous espérons et nous
sommes nombreuses à l'espérer nous
espérons un projet de loi
constitutionnel qui nous permettent
d'aller plus rapidement sur cette
question
je veux ici remercier chaleureusement et
sincèrement l'ensemble des collègues
députés qui ont permis de recueillir la
sentiment de leur groupe et de
travailler à cette formulation
transparisane je remercie Mélanie Vogel
qui courentusement au Sénat à porter
cette question il y a un mois je
remercie évidemment l'administrateur
monsieur Joly mais l'ensemble aussi des
services de l'assemblée qui ont fait un
travail remarquable je veux enfin dédier
cette victoire historique que nous
envoyons à la fois comme signal à notre
pays mais au monde aux femmes des
États-Unis aux femmes de Pologne aux
femmes de Hongrie dont le droit à
l'avortement et aujourd'hui on travaille
mais aussi et elles sont là aujourd'hui
aux militants qui dans notre pays
lutte au quotidien pour le droit des
femmes à disposer de leur corps je vous
remercie